генератор нічого
більше Як вам буде
один два
раз раз раз
давайте вони пройдуть Я ж можу їх
покласти
добре
человек мікрофон раз раз Все ок
а следующий мікрофон раз раз
уже новий мікрофон нормально 4
і останній мікрофон все супер
раз раз раз раз раз раз
І що щось чути А я чую
чути чути
колеги вітаю я сподіваюсь мене чути це
досить дивний для мене формат
комунікації але будемо звикати Мене
звати Роксолана швачак Я директор
директорату цифрової трансформації не
чути не чути а люди інші кажуть чути Ви
маєте навушник Я директор директорату
цифрової трансформації мон другий канал
Я директор директора та цифрової
трансформації мон і є координатором
власне цієї сцени з нами також присутня
Анна Сидорук яка є куратором цієї сцени
і ми будемо сьогодні протягом сьогодні
допомагати вам на цій сцені відповідати
на питання і загалом організаційно
підтримувати Я дуже дякую вам всім що ви
тут зібралися насправді Для нас це
велика несподіванка і честь що так
багато є прихильників діджіталізації
тому дякуємо вам за це я маю сказати
декілька протокольних речей в разі якщо
в нас буде повітряна тривога Ми всі
маємо йти в укриття найближчий вихід в
нас позаду нашої сцени в шоу-румі
освітніх інновацій
евакуаційний вихід і ми маємо всі разом
туди прямувати пізніше ми будемо
орієнтуватися на те як буде по часу
повітряна тривога і Як ми далі Будемо
продовжувати свою сцену далі по
навушниках я хотіла сказати всім що
потрібно взяти навушники але я так
розумію що ті хто мене не чують і так
цього не почують тому тому Да будемо
розбиратися по ходу просто
і щось я хотіла сказати що позаду нашої
сцени є шоурум освітніх інновацій де є
наші представлені атек-партнери освітні
стартапи ви там зможете підписати
сертифікат роботом рукою за участь в
цьому в цій конференції ви зможете там
подивитися голограми і багато чого
іншого тому будь ласка Запрошуємо всіх
вас в перервах між панелями я не
затримую час запрошую на першу панель
наших спікерів і модератора цієї панелі
Дмитра Завгороднього заступника міністра
освіти інуки з питань цифрового розвитку
цифрових трансформацій і цифровізації
дякую
Доброго дня всім Мене звати Дмитро
Загородній я заступник міністра освіти і
науки України відповідаю за цифрову
трансформацію А ще за
професійно-технічною фахового передвищу
освіту і сподіваюся що ми презентацію
сюди
Я зазвичай я бачу що більшість людей які
зараз присутні і сподіваюся що ті хто
нас дивляться онлайн теж знають про
Багато наших
все ще залишається в Харківській області
на деокупованих територіях Миколаївській
області і мають доступ доступ виключно
до дистанційного навчання тому ми дуже
хотіли щоб воно було якіснішим ви можете
побачити фотографії інших дітей які мене
дуже вражає приклад От цю дівчинку яка
всередині її звати Каміла Наскільки я
знаю вода йде в 6-й клас
шостий клас шостий клас Як ви знаєте
вона йде за програмою нової української
школи давайте просто уявимо собі як
виглядало взагалі шкільне навчання цієї
дитини тобто коли вона пішла десь класу
другий чи в третій почалась пандемія та
у неї почалося онлайн навчання далі вона
вчилася вдома з батьками з бабусею яка
вчила її читати і писати і так далі
потім почалася війна у неї продовжилась
онлайн навчання теж десь в ізюмському
районі далі було дуже важко вони
переїхали переїхали назад і так далі І
коли вони пішли в п'ятий клас під час
війни в їхню школу навіть не привезли
підручників так крім підручника з
математики який нам допоміг і оплатив
юнісеф і який вона отримала більше в
п'ятому класі У них підручників не було
Зараз вони йдуть шостий клас у їхні
вчителів нова програма вони будуть
викладати за новою програмою онлайн
і е насправді ну найкраще що якби мені
здається що Нам вдалося зробити це те що
ми точно знаємо що у неї буде комп'ютер
за яким вона зможе відвідувати нашу
школу онлайн на якій вже є програма
нової української школи є уроки у її
вчительки є теж комп'ютер Ми впевнені що
у школі в якій вчителька може працювати
є інтернет і так далі тобто Мені
здається що це просто дивовижно важливо
насправді зараз можна в наступний слайд
Я не знаю
а туди Я зрозумів
півмільйона дітей це ті діти які
зараховані зараз в українські школи які
знаходяться за кордоном
на жаль я сподіваюся що багато з них
найближчим часом буде повертатися але й
Ці діти навчаються дистанційно і нам
дуже потрібно розвивати наші школи в
напрямку того щоб ця послуга
дистанційного навчання була якісною для
дітей які знаходяться за кордоном
бачите
Анастасія вчиться в Миколаївській
області Вона вчиться в закладі
профтехосвіти і теж отримала свій
персональний ромбук цього року
Анастасія жила в Миколаєві Я не
переключався Анастасія жила в Миколаєві
але на жаль в будинок в якому вона жила
влучила ракета тепер вона живе в
Миколаївській області і вчиться онлайн
я Мені важко собі уявити в професійному
ліцеї якщо вона наприклад на найбільш
популярній професії в Україні зараз це
кухар
як от в сучасній Україні можна чомусь
навчитися якщо у вас немає наприклад
комп'ютера Да вот ви розумієте що ви не
можете зайти подивитися на те як готують
тут саму їжу в Ютубі не можете
зв'язатися з вашим учителем в Зумі там і
так далі і тому подібне Тобто нам як На
мою думку це просто така базова потреба
яка в нас є
Я просто ненавиджу це крикер
більш ніж мільйон дітей в Україні вже з
початку повномасштабної війни навчається
в змішаній формі Тобто це означає що
декілька предметів або декілька днів на
тиждень у них немає можливості просто
навчатись офлайн Тобто їм теж потрібно
інтернет потрібен комп'ютер ця школа має
функціонувати так само як і Та яка
дистанційна повністю загалом це вже
більше половини всіх дітей в Україні і в
регіонах таких як Харківська область
Миколаївська область це Майже всі діти
які так чи інакше стикаються з
дистанційним навчанням кожного тижня
добре Ідемо далі там був слайд що більш
ніж 35 тисяч дітей цього року отримали
персональні девайси і ще більш ніж 10
тисяч дітей їх отримають На жаль цього
взагалі недостатньо Тобто це фантастичні
цифри яких раніше в Україні не було щоб
Ми прям для дітей давали девайси і так
далі але цього ну вистачає менш ніж там
на 10%. від всіх тих дітей які з різних
подібних історій подібних вразливих
категорій переміщення особи діти сироти
і так далі які всі мають отримати свій
персональний гаджет які всі мають
отримати доступ до освіти
Це вчителька з Запорізької області Яка
теж переїхала вона з Мелітополя і зараз
викладаю в місті Запоріжжя у неї 30
років стаж роботи і На жаль вона не може
повернутися в ту школу в якій вона
викладала раніше але вона працює
продовжує працювати продовжує працювати
з ноутбуком який її доставили і таких
вчителів вчителів яким які отримали ці
девайси більш ніж 150 тисяч за ці два
роки На жаль цього теж недостатньо і ще
є 80 тисяч вчителів різних категорій в
різних містах яким теж потрібен
персональний девайс
далі хотів сказати про те що важко
уявити як всій ситуації під час війни
під час пандемії школа от Ці вчителі
переміщені діти по всій країні працюють
якщо в них немає системи управління
школи якщо в них немає системи
управління навчання на щастя вже більш
ніж 70% станом на зараз шкіл які обрали
той чи інший електронний журнал або
систему управління навчання і поступово
замінюють свої паперові документи на
електронні я пам'ятаю як ми коли
почалася пандемія спілкувалась стосовно
впровадження електронних журналів школи
і казали що дивіться от зараз вчителька
теж важливо просто уявляти історіями
вчителька має після того як вона вдома
провела онлайн уроки записати оцінки в
щоденник в тетрадку потім піти в школу
знайти той журнал проставити оцінки якщо
вчителька зараз за кордоном через війну
вона ці оцінки скидає на на Viber своїй
подрузі іншій вчительці яка заноситься в
паперовий журнал і так далі з 2023 році
ми сподіваємося що все більше і більше
шкіл від цього відмовляться і будуть
вести все в електронному вигляді дуже
багато для цього зробили і Що зробимо
важливо зрозуміти чому я це все
розповідаю тому що більшість людей які
зараз це слухають Я просто це знаю на
100% долучені до того що це стає правдою
і На жаль ми дуже багато розказуємо або
окремо про наші потреби що все дуже
погано Нам дуже потрібно ще багато
комп'ютерів в школах Все ще немає
електронних журналів на все ще не
вистачає електронного контенту або Він
погано працює якісь вчителям щось не
подобається і так далі але теж або
розказуємо про наші результати як багато
ми всього зробили мені хотілося
продемонструвати що ми знаходимося десь
посередині дуже великого шляху від того
коли почалася пандемія і
здавалося що дистанційна освіта це щось
фантастичне і до того до чого ми всі
прагнемо коли вчителька буде приходити
нова молода в школу їй будуть видавати
коробочку в якій буде новий комп'ютер
все буде в електронному вигляді і вона ж
може працювати з дома або з іншої країни
все буде автоматично і не буде
бюрократії Я дуже вдячний всім хто
долучений до того щоб зробити це
реальністю в найближчому майбутньому
дуже вам дякую
Так точно точно мені просто я себе чую
паралельно це достатньо важко
так а тепер ми переходимо до того щоб
оголосити весь наш список гостей почну з
валерією і аннан Валерія будь ласка
заступник Міністра цифрової
трансформації України яка відповідає за
цифровізацію освіти за цифрову освіту
наш головний партнер
Дякую
рама на хармісру спеціаліст з розвитку
технологій юнісеф Україна
Анна Сидорук операційна директорка
громадської спілки освіторія
[оплески]
та Олег Якимчук директор з питань
взаємодії
підключаться онлайн директор з питань
взаємодії з органами державної влади
Google Україна ми його Побачимо тут
потім підключиться онлайн дякую то я
сідаю тоді
так
Дякую вам що прийшли до нас сьогодні
перше питання У нас буде до пані Валерії
Валерія нам дуже допомагає як І взагалі
все Міністерство цифрової трансформації
і дуже багато робить для того щоб
освіта стала цифровою і для того щоб в
першу чергу люди могли здобути цифрові
навички за допомогою цих нових
інструментів Але нещодавно
проекти яким займаються Валерія вони
розширилися не лише на цифрові навички
будь ласка розкажи нам що сталося І що
нам чекати далі Так дякую тепер моя
черга спробувати цей клікер і цей
мікрофон Я сподіваюся що ви добре мене
чуєте і все клас А так бачу бачу все
добре дякую Діма тобі дуже за
представлення і дякую за запрошення за
організацію цієї панелі Дійсно я в
міністерстві опікуюсь різними напрямками
різними проектами але Враховуючи те У
нас сьогодні обмежений час Я би дуже
хотіла вам розповісти про один із наших
топових проектів це дія освіта Ну як ви
всі знаєте ми будуємо найбільш цифрову
державу у світі ви напевно всі знаєте
про наш застосунок дія але ви також
напевно Знаєте що А у нас є ціла
екосистема проектів дія яка включає в
себе п'ять різних проектів Тобто це
застосунок це дія Сіті це діє
бізнес-проект з розвитку підприємництва
і в тому числі це дія освіта
взагалі коли Міністерство цифрової
трансформації було сформовано у 19-му
році Ми зрозуміли що однією з наших
стратегічних цілей має бути навчити
українців цифрової грамотності тому що
якщо ми будуємо найбільш цифрову державу
у світі нам потрібно щоб кожен мав
принаймні базові цифрові навички для
того щоб користуватися тими послугами
тими бенефітами які створює держава але
також сьогодні цифрова грамотність - це
так само важливо як вміти можете писати
і говорити і це дорівнює
конкурентоспроможність ми не знаємо Я
зараз дуже часто це повторюю на
конференціях Цю тезу що ми не знаємо що
буде за 3-5 років з ринком професії ми
не знаємо які нові професії будуть які
професії конкретно замінить штучний
інтелект ми це можемо припускати Але то
ще те що ми знаємо точно що цифрова
грамотність вона буде дуже важливою і
саме вона допоможе швидко переключатися
між професіями Подивіться на ті напрямки
Які розвиваються зараз у світі це медтех
біотех клейматех агрітех фоттех що
спільного між ними тег Тобто це означає
що потрібно бути спеціалістом в
декількох сферах одночасно тож власне
Одна з наших стратегічних цілей на
самому початку було навчити 6 млн
українців цифрові грамотності але ми
хотіли зрозуміти яка точка 0 Де ми зараз
знаходимося і в 19-му році ми вперше
провели національне дослідження яке
показало нам ще 53%
українців мають цифрову грамотність
нижче базового рівня із цим потрібно
було щось власне робити тому ми створили
проект який на той час називався дія
цифрова освіта це національно-освітня
платформа яка розміщувала освітні
серіали у форматі едітеймент тобто
навчання через розваги у форматі
мікронавчання стопу років тестів для
того щоб навчити різні сегменти цільової
аудиторії цифровим навичкам в 21-му році
ми повторно провели дослідження яке
показало що результати покращились на
5%. і фактично Майже півтора мільйони
людей які взагалі не мали ніяких базових
навичок от от їх отримали Але знову ж
таки там платформа розвивалась проект
розвивався ми робили досить багато
різних проектів різних напрямках
напрямках створювали офлайн хаби Але ми
всі знаємо що світ турбулентний і
постійно з'являється нові нові виклики
Один із найбільших цю нашу країну настиг
минуло високо це одномасштабне російське
вторгнення яке спричинило виклики в
різних сферах в тому числі в сфері
освіти і в сфері економіки в нас є дуже
багато ВПУ які На жаль досі
залишаються безробітними тобто вони не
можуть знайти роботу є великий попит на
перекваліфікацію є великий попит на
підвищення цифрових грамотності і саме
це спонукало нас до того щоб в травні
місяці ми зробили релончик платформи
діяо освіта за підтримки наших партнерів
google.org та фонду Східної Європи і
зараз я вам трошки детальніше про цю
платформу розповім вона є безкоштовною
для всіх і кожен зможе навчитися дуже
різним класним навичкам ну перш за все
там є 150 освітніх серіалів вони
присвячені або конкретним навичкам або
конкретним професіям наприклад в нас є
блок зразки є 50 професій половина з них
цифрові половина з них не цифрові зараз
я вам покажу коротеньке відео про те щоб
би мало уявлення про сам контент на
платформі
тут А немає звуку
так мені показує 3 хвилини значить я маю
щось переключити вашу увагу на щось інше
власне
150 серіалів тести а також інтерактивні
симулятори тому сьогодні на платформі
безпосередньо ми можемо знайти серіали в
декільках категоріях Ми також
експериментували з форматами які
дозволять з підвищити рівень залученості
наших користувачів І тому ми створили
такий формат який називається
інтерактивний симулятор це коли ти можеш
прожити день з певної професії маєш 10
кейсів і тобі потрібно обрати правильно
чи неправильну відповідь і побачити
відеоекспромation тобто насправді ми
постійно експериментуємо з новими
форматами на нашій платформі і бачимо що
навчаємося на своїх помилках і
намагаємося робити її ще більше і більш
зручною поки колеги там щось
розбираються з відео Я думаю ми підемо
далі по презентації І власне хочу
зробити невели анонс що вже в цьому
навчальному році у вересні на платформі
також буде доступна доступна оновлена
інформатика або it-студії для школярів
це величезний масштабний проект над яким
працювала велика команда і в минулому
році він вплотувався 50 школах в цьому
році ми вже будемо безпосередньо
запускати його на всі школи говорячи про
професії Я сказала що в нас є половина
цифрових половини не цифрових частин з
них ви можете побачити безпосередньо на
екрані платформа безкоштовна відкрита
для кожного за посиланням освіта дія
gov.ua також платформа доступна в
українському варіанті та в англійському
варіанті Тобто можна переглядати всі
серіали англійською мовою і ще й
підвищувати свій рівень безпосередньо
англійської мови Окрім цього на
платформі є величезна кількість Гайді в
подкасців вебінарів корисних посилань і
власне ось тут ви можете побачити без
звуку сам симулятор як виглядає
наприклад з професії кондитерава
наприклад за кредитування книжки
перестало
давайте почекаємо якогось хорошого
позитивного знаку від технічної команди
його поки немає тому йдемо далі також на
платформі є можливість створити
персональну траєкторію навчання основна
ідея заключається в тому що ви можете
обрати ці навички які ви хочете
підвищити і платформа вам запропонує не
просто серіали а конкретні епізоди з
різних серіалів з яких ви сформуєте
власну освітню траєкторію ми плануємо
йти далі І далі і покращувати власне
безпосередньо всі ці результати Ну і
найголовніше ще те що враховуючи питання
розслідування з квілінгу ми зробили
Повний цикл на платформі доступний який
заключається в тому що умовно якщо
людина
уявімо доросла людина або наприклад
Студент не може визначитися з професією
Він проходить профорієнтаційний тест за
результатами профорієнтаційного тесту ми
йому одразу показу варіанти професій які
доступні на платформі і які можуть бути
йому цікавими після цього людину
навчається освітньому серіалі проходить
інтерактивний симулятор отримує
сертифікат і одразу бачить не просто
каталог вакансій з пошуку роботи а
відкриті вакансії по цій професії в тому
регіоні де знаходиться людина і одразу
може заплакатися це одно означає що з
одного освітнього серіалу можна стати
професіоналом але з одного освітнього
серіалу можна зрозуміти про що ця
професія чи вона тобі підходить
зрозуміти які навички потрібні щось
навіть спробувати зробити вдома і Ну
скажімо якщо людина пропрацювала 15
років економістом чи юристом для неї
вона вже не починає з нуля і набагато
легше стати проектним менеджером чи
проти менеджером і вона це може зробити
безпосередньо на нашій платформі Також
ми працюємо з тим щоб дати доступ до
цієї платформи навіть тим людям в кого
по якимось причинам вдома немає гаджетів
чи доступу до Інтернету і в нас є мережа
Fly highbi на базі бібліотек шкіл
університетів яка доступна для кожного І
ми навчаємо наших адміністраторів
бібліотекарів фасилітаторів робити
перший контакт для людей елегантного
віку з гаджетами і для того щоб вони
мали можливість безпосередньо навчатися
Також у нас є окрема програма тренінг
для тренерів як це також програма яка
доступна безкоштовно на платформі і
безпосередньо після цього можна далі
допомагати іншим опановувати цифрові
навички
власне портал доступний за посиланням
освіта діє.gov.ua тут є qr-код в нас ці
гаряча лінія підтримки для ваших
пропозицій коментарів
навіть критики з якими дуже любимо Ми
відкриті до співпраці з бізнесом з
експертами і фактично багато контенту
якими створюємо Ми створюємо самі
партнерстві з бізнесом тому що То як не
підприємці краще знають кого вони хочуть
бачити своїми працівниками сьогодні
завтра і через певний час власне
презентація не вдалася на 100%, як
планувалися але я сподіваюся що Вам вся
інформація була цікава і ми чекаємо вас
на порталі освіти дієгою дякую
Дякую
величезне і за все що ви робите в
міністерстві і за ту підтримку яку ми
отримуємо безпосередньо всі ці роки наше
співпраці а далі знову про підтримку яку
ми отримуємо
Вітаю рам Я так розумію що ти чуєш
переклад англійською мовою правильно
я хотів запитати юнісеф один з наших
найбільших партнерів як Міністерство
освіти так і освіти в Україні взагалі я
думаю один з найбільших гуманітарних
партнерів протягом війни змогу досвіду
роботи з
юнісеф це зовсім інша організація
починаючи з 24 лютого працювати з ними
цікаво динамічно і ми дуже багато
зробили разом від модернізації
наповнення школи онлайн до десятків
тисяч комп'ютерів які отримали діти і ще
отримають рам будь ласка розкажи як ти
думаєш чого Нам вдалось досягти може що
нам потрібно ще зробити як погляд з боку
юнісеф на на ті челенджі які у нас є
Я не діюся що ви чуєте мене
там мікрофон ледь працює
особлива подяка
зробіть щось там треба включити мікрофон
не працює мікрофон Ні ні працює Ми чуємо
Я не чую перекладач не чую
інший мікрофон дайте йому будь ласка
навчається давайте зрозуміємо
що в Україні допомагає
разом з партнером з громадянського
суспільства
навчання і середовище відповідно для
надати всі можливості всі інструменти
для навчання і так би мовити
певну реабілітацію навіть
і забезпечити
дівайсами пристроями відповідними
інноваційні рішення забезпечення
і це можна буде побачити більш детально
і щоб підтримувати навчання і освіту для
дітей
Оскільки ми ці школи
закриваються то є потреба
для того щоб відновили діти і наздогнали
в освітній програмі ворота вручає
відповідні нові програми а остання але
не менше це розвивати навички
для дітей і відповідні навички в освіті
Цей діалог в основному
освіти
Стараємося зробити для того щоб
поліпшити якість
спеціалізація в Україні
це допомогти щоб девайся пристрої були в
руках уже
щоб діти могли використовувати чого вони
в онлайні
платформи для версії оскільки Україна
стає більше
слухайте в доступ до цифрових смартфонів
які мають особливі потреби особливо для
дітей які мають спеціальні покраси
Оскільки
ми бачимо і вони мають
проблем Ми хочемо впевнитися і
переконатися Якщо ніхто не залишився
навчити фасилітатор щоб вони навчилися
новим програмним забезпеченням
що не підходить звичайно
спроможність вчителів збільшили з
покращувалася і що вони були
хороші навички і вони просувалися
для дітей щоб вони в онлайні
соціалізуватися і взаємодіяти з іншими і
інколи дітям це потрібно вивчення тому
що вони вже багато років не ходять в
школу і
там немає Києва людей
28 28
[музика]
потребами щоб вони мали доступ до
освітньої платформи для того щоб вони
більш легко отримали доступ до освіти
тобто інклюзивна освіта щоб була
Іщенко
тобто
Minecraft
освітня програма яка столиця якійсь
туремент
то ти відповідні центри це цифрової
освіти і навчання
цей новація
партнером нашим суспільства
підприємством щоб вони були
документи
створити таке середовище де ми працюємо
з урядом і з партнерами з громадянського
суспільства
дуже вам дякую за увагу
[оплески]
так переходячи далі я хочу сказати що
крім великих міжнародних організацій нам
дуже-дуже сильно допомагають локальні
українські громадські організації які
насправді роблять дуже багато роботи і
для юнісеф і для всіх наших міжнародних
партнерів і насправді є такою
найважливішою Я думаю підтримкою для
системи освіти для нас як міністерства в
першу чергу
тому вітаю Аня і хочу одразу запитати в
тебе
про ваш досвід і про ну історію які
ставалися за час війни за час нашого
партнерства з освітою ми зробили дуже
багато проектів в першу чергу це
всеукраїнська школа онлайн і весь той
контент який ми почали робити ще коли
почалася пандемія ще коли навіть він
відбувався в форматі телевізійних уроків
і так далі І цей проект продовжується
наша Партнерство і співпраця Які
розвиваються але думаю що в тебе є
багато багато цікавого що за цей час
сталося І про що можна розповідати
лікарем передбачивши те що доволі часто
на дискусіях якщо стосується інновацій
технологій цифровізація відбувається
якісь технічні негаразди тож поговоримо
про історію
ви знаєте від початку війни Ми з
командою розвернули розвернули такий
проект який Ми назвали redication штаб
невідкладної освітньої допомоги і щодня
ми отримуємо заявки їх вже понад півтори
тисячі з запитами про те чим ми можемо
допомогти це якийсь швидкий запити які
допоможуть відновити навчальний процес в
школах з різних питань І от нас особливо
торкнула Історія однієї школи з міста
Бахмут директорка школа описала про те
що її будинок знищено її школу знищено
її місто власне знищено але не знищено
школу тому що школа існує і досі поза
межами самого приміщення
і ця школа попросила нас допомогти
сформуванням такого цифрового середовища
тому що як не крути але й досі в
багатьох регіонах дистанційка це
відправити у Viber сторінки мені кивають
Я розумію що це так відбувається деінде
сторінки з домашнім завданням і отримати
у відповідь вирішенні завдання але це не
так
має бути тому ми з командою взяли собі
амбітну ціль допомогти тим школам які
наразі працюють виключно в дистанційному
або змішаному форматі зробити так що
якщо дистанційка відбувається щоб це
було якісно і цікаво тому от якраз з
нашими партнерами з юнісеф Міністерство
освіти з Minecraft з Microsoft Google Ми
плануємо від навчати понад 11 тисяч
вчителів і тренерів локальних в кожному
регіоні якісні організації дистанційного
змішаного навчання це буде величезний
проект на наступні 18 місяців але
організація під ключ з формуванням
цифрового освітнього середовища з
методологією з контентом І звісно ж тими
інструментами які ми вже наразі створили
для української освіти також поділюся
декількома новинками що є в продуктах
тих яких Ми створюємо окрім тих навчань
для вчителів для освітніх управлінців
тощо всеукраїнська школа онлайн Про яку
вже трошки зазначив Дмитро станом на
зараз має понад 500 тисяч зареєстрованих
користувачів і понад два мільйони
унікальних користувачів які не
зареєстровані Тому що під час війни Ми
зняли обов'язково реєстрацію
Зараз наша команда працює на дуже
важливим проектом от прямо буквально
зараз поки я тут розповідаю у нас
відбувається зйомки уроків з
кримськотатарської мови тому що
понад 6 тисяч учнів у і досі
прямо зараз навчаються на всеукраїнській
школі онлайн просто уявіть після 9 років
окупація коли там висять триколорії
ходять російські рублі
Українці продовжують вивчати там
українську мову історію
культуру а відтепер ще будуть вивчати
кримськотатарську мову з найкращими
вчителями тому ми цим дуже сильно
пишаємося також команда працює над тим
що ми запускаємо інтегровані нові курси
для нової української школи з 5-го по
сьомий клас
інтегровані курси мовної галузі те про
що ми дуже давно мріяли українська мова
українська література зарубіжна
література буде викладатися по-новому
цікаво і інтегровано тому що це єдиний
процес
я вже з нетерпінням чекаю коли ці уроки
з'являться зрештою на вишиванку вже
зараз там до речі понад з половиною
тисячі уроків І щодня ставатиме все
більше і більше Також ми працюємо і вже
я думаю з жовтня місяця з’являться перші
уроки з громадянської освіти що є дуже
важливо особливо зараз і викладати ці
уроки будуть знову ж таки наші найкращі
експерти патріоти ті які сьогодні
вирощують майбутнє за своїми партами
тому пишаємося і теж з нетерпінням
чекаємо
другий продукт над яким ми активно
працюємо це наш мобільний застосунок для
початкової школи вивчаємо Не чекаю
мобільний класний сучасний інтерактивний
застосунок для школярів від першого по
четвертий клас мій син До речі йому 6
років він один знає активніших
користувачів і наш головний критик тому
ми постійно оновлюємо контент оновлюємо
сам застосунок І власне вже на початку
вересня ви всі теж побачите результати
зокрема його критики теж на вас чекає
чимало оновленнь класні якісні міні-ігри
анімовані мультяшні відеоуроки
інтерактивні цікаві тести і ще багато
іншого але ми подумали не лише про дітей
тому що дітей у нас наразі є понад 60
тисяч активних користувачів але ми ще й
працюємо над дисктопною версією для
вчителів для того щоб вчителі прямо на
своїх уроках в класі могли працювати
разом з дітьми над проектами вже
використовуючи навчальний танк який є в
застосунку вивчає Не чекаю або ж що ще
цікаво якщо сталося так що навчальний
процес відбувається дистанційно то
вчитель може запросити до віртуального
класу своїх учнів і грати і вивчати
одночасно інтерактивно в своєму такому
віртуальному класі це те над чим ми
працюємо І звісно ж для того щоб вчителі
мали змогу як найефективніше
використовувати всі ці знання
Ми працюємо над таким посібником знову ж
таки інтерактивним як і всі наші
продукти для того щоб вчителі
використовуючи контент-проекту вивчаю Не
чекаю вже мали готові плани уроків мали
якісну методологію і могли проводити
навчальний процес
цікаво якісно незважаючи від того де
вони є сьогодні чи вони є в класі чи
вони є в укриті чи вони є абсолютно
дистанційно Чи це вчителька яка ще має
групу дітей і навчає їх українській мові
наших маленьких українців які
знаходяться наразі за кордоном і такий
спосіб підтримують свій зв'язок з
Україною ось це з таких ключових новинок
те над чим працюємо але там плани В нас
амбітні і багато дякую дякую тобі Дякую
за чудову роботу
далі ми переходимо до нашого онлайн
гостя Олега якимчука З компанії Google
Олег нас чує бачить відчуває
нашу присутність
Зараз ми може якщо його побачимо або
почуємо то ми зрозуміємо що він на
зв'язку
а поки ми його не бачимо Я хотів сказати
що
спочатку війни ми от з Роксоланою з
іншими колегами з міністерства разом з
валерією з колегами з міністерства
цифрової трансформації взагалі в перші
дні почали писати листи в безліч
компанії по всьому світу і звертатися в
їхні українські представництва і
міжнародні офіси і так далі з тим що нам
потрібно допомога і це були Взагалі всі
виробники техніки яких ми просто змогли
знайти назву всі прізвища які ми змогли
знайти в лінктині писали їм влічку
писали їм email офіційні листи і так
далі І дуже багато нам компаній
допомогло врешті багато компаній вийшли
з російського ринку багато компаній
зробили якісь донейшини для нас або
допомагали нам експертизу і так далі
однією з таких компаній була і
залишається компанія Google з якою у нас
мабуть ну з точки зору бізнес-партнерів
може найбільша співпраця Ми отримали
десятки тисяч хромбуків дуже багато вони
нам допомагають навчання вчителів
цифрової грамотністю і буде багато
проектів попереду
Олеже Вітаю ми тепер вас бачимо і
сподіваюся що ми вас почуємо ми хотіли
вас запитати чому компанія Google нам
допомагає як Дмитро Шановні колеги Вітаю
Google дійсно активна допомагає Україні
і українським освітянам протягом усього
періоду масштабної війни проте насправді
Ця історія нашої співпраці з
міністерством освіти і науки триває вже
майже 10 років у подорож усього цього
часу ми запередилися на таких напрямках
як впровадження інноваційних технологій
в освіті та науці підвищення цифрової
грамотності освітян безпека дітей в
інтернеті а також стандарти інклюзії в
освіті
в межах компанії цифрового перетворення
регіонів України ми побачили перше
відчуття результати 23 тисячі освітяни з
різних куточків України взяли участь в
онлайні і офлайн-тренінгу то відкритих
уроках для покращення цифрових навичок і
ще 22 тисячі вчителів долучилися до
створення
безпечнішого онлайн-простору для учнів
завдяки нашому посібнику посібнику
Google з безпеки дітей в інтернеті
локалізованому якраз разом з
міністерством освіти і науки
пандемія ковід-19
засвідчила всю нагальність питання
централізації освіти та перетворила його
з пріоритету вона критично необхідне Тож
ми теж були рабні допомогти українським
освітянам опанувати цифрові навички для
впровадження інструментів дистанційного
навчання і до
2022 року в таких навчальних ініціативах
взяли участь вже понад 1000
освітян початок повно російського
вторгнення загрожував зупинити все про
те Україна і освітяни довели що навіть
під час війни необхідно жити та
розвиватися аби підтримати українських
вчителів що продовжили навчати попри все
спільно з юнеском ми передали 50 тисяч
пристроїв промбул там хороші традиції
співпраці а також відкритість
Міністерства до державного приватного
партнерства допомогли нам швидко та
масштабно реалізувати можливість такої
допомоги додатково до передачі ноутбуків
ми організували навчальну програму
цифрові інструменти Google для освіти і
тепер вже лише рік за учасниками стала
більше ніж 200 000 освітян
дуже велика цифра також українські школи
отримали оновлення Chromebook Chrome
Enterprise а близько 100 українських
університетів де скористалися
безкоштовним річним доступом до
оновлення Google Space Edition
Upgrade була представлена низко освітніх
платформ та інструментів та Google
знання містить корисні ресурси для
навчання роботи та повсякденного життя
платформа навчайте де б ви не були
відкриваючи найбільші можливостей
пристроїв комбук та цифри реалізації
інструментів Google а онлайн гра
інтер-ленд допомагає цікаво навчитися
основ безпечного поводження в мережі для
дітей Ми продовжуємо створити новий
можливості для взуття разом з Google
зокрема в межах нових ініціатив із
медіаграмотності та безпеки дітей онлайн
до нашого спеціалізованого підрозділу
Google chromedication Про що ви зможете
детальніше
дізнатися від мого колеги Вільяма
Флоранс який буде виступати пізніше
так у тісній співпраці з міністерством
освіти і науки ми розбудовуємо цифрову
екосистему для підтримки і розвитку
українських української освіти і
українських освітян тож Дозвольте мені
від Google ще раз подякувати
міністерству освіти і науки за плідно
співпрацю Я абсолютно впевнений у і
успішному продовженні і хочу побажати
всім учасникам та гостям продуктивної
дискусії Які заходи дійсно окреслюють
нові сенси і напрями розвитку освіти а
освіта в свою чергу допомагає визначити
ректор подальшого розвитку України
дякую вам
і дякую компанії Google за надзвичайну
допомогу
у нас просто ідеальний таймінг по
закінченню часу на який ми розраховували
але оскільки ми почали пізніше то в нас
залишається ще чудовий час на те щоб ви
могли задати ваші запитання будь-кому з
нас з наших гостей спікерів будь ласка
підіймайте руку задавайте будь-яке
запитання так
цікавить питання щодо застосунку вивчає
не чекають тільки в смартфоні
ми користуємося дуже подобається наразі
тільки в смартфоні Але як я вже сказала
зараз команда працює над створенням
дископної версії тобто вже з ноутбуку Чи
з іншого будь-якого девайсу ви зможете
також використовувати і працювати Це або
в класі або навіть дистанційно в такому
віртуальному кабінеті з вашими учнями на
початку вересня ну моя команда каже 11
вересня але я ще дату не готова
оголосити аж так фінально але це будуть
перші числа вересня коли ми презентуємо
всі ці оновлення і зможете вже працювати
з ноутбуком зокрема
луєм калина Харківське it-кластер хочемо
подякувати за співпрацю в цьому році
нашу спільнота долучилася і до створення
відео до ітістудії і відповідно маю таке
питання Чи плануєте залучати
роботодавців ще та яким чином Валерія до
вас скоріше за все
Так Дуже дякую Ну по-перше дякую
Харківському за вашу за нашу плідну
співпрацю і за вашу роботу дуже класне
запитання так Ну по-перше ми наш план це
запустити it-студії вже масштабно вже у
вересні і ми сподіваємося побачити перші
такі вже серйозні результати протягом
двох трьох місяців ми вже в рамках
пілоту отримали багато фідбеку багато
чого покращили але ми думаємо що фідбек
ще будуть з'являтися це буде такий живий
організм що стосується роботодавців
по-перше ми завжди відкриті В нас дуже
багато є можливостей для співпраці якщо
ми говоримо про якісь студії то знову ж
таки це створення додаткового контенту
тому що світ технологій звідси
провізації дуже турбулентний постійно
щось з'являється штучний інтелект
взагалі буде одна із ключових тем на
найближчих 3-5 років тому тут будемо
залучати кампанії для того щоб
створювати контент і до підготовки
молодого
наступного покоління з іншого боку в нас
є проект наприклад дієосвіта в якому
сьогодні є 50 професій але ми плануємо
не плануємо зупинятися на цьому і наша
основна задача дата якомога більше
освітнього контенту для людей які хочуть
професію змінити або покращити свою
навички і Саме тут бізнес для нас є
ключовим партнером тому що якщо ви
подивитеся на кожен з цих продуктів ви
побачите яка компанія нам допомагала
його створювати саме в контексті
контенту так тому закликаю харківські ці
кластер і взагалі є інший ті кластери
Якщо є бажання до створення спільних
освітніх продуктів і є бажання до
спільного пошуку
цікавих форматів ми готові я хочу
сказати нещодавно можливо не думаю що
освітяни всі знають а там нещодавно
вийшов в один такий звіт проте про
технології в навчальному процесі там
була така
фраза яку можна читати під різними
кутами вона заключалась в тому що
позитивний вплив використання технологій
в освітньому процесі не доведений
але що в цьому найбільше є зацікавленими
вендери і я коли це прочитала я дуже
сильно розізлилася насправді тому що
освітній процес це не просто про те щоб
мати
ноутбук не просто про те щоб мати
планшет чи смартфон і мати доступ до
платформи де є контент
це
класно найсухе але
справжній освітній процес це коли
технології інтегровані процес навчання
Тобто це коли в тебе
є багато різних інструментів коли в тебе
навчання без технологів в принципі
неможливо так але технології сьогодні
відкривають все більше і більше нових
можливостей для кожного з нас починаючи
від умовного дошкілля закінчуючи вже
коли людина працює і вона переходить на
етап навчання протягом життя я вам скажу
в мене в Моєму сину один рік і вісім
місяців вже забуваю скільки як правильно
рахувати але я йому завантажила один із
додатків і
кожен день по 5-7 хвилин ми з ним
практикуємо вивчення слів і якісь дуже
практичні речі і за місяць я бачу
надзвичайний прогрес
і мені здається що ми зараз знаходимось
на такому етапі коли
має бути ось цей золотий трикутник
держава бізнес і
громадські організації ми маємо спільне
об'єднуватись спільно створювати спільно
трансформуватися систему освіти спільно
давати нові класні рішення
тому що для нас для всіх нас з вами
розвиток людського капіталу І взагалі да
тобто розвиток наших людей в Україні має
стати пріоритетом №1 бо Від цього
залежить все
тому да дуже розлога відповідь вийшла на
ваше запитання але
хотіла просто сказати що технології в
освітньому процесі це дуже важливо
контент важливий потрібно шукати нові
формати це не тільки про імерсивне
навчання навчання вмити всесвіті в
університеті можна ще зробити крок назад
і знайти дуже класні інші формати такі
як наприклад симулятори Надія освіти або
на інших платформах або застосунок про
який договорили Анна і тому якщо у вас є
ідея тому нам треба всім разом сміливо в
цьому експериментувати дякую
[оплески]
наступне питання
ні в кого немає запитань більше
можемо переходити до наступної частини
якщо нікого немає запитань тоді дякую
всім Дякую за вашу надзвичайну допомогу
Дякую за те що ви робите ці цікаві і
надзвичайно корисні проекти я
Сподіваємось що ми цього року ще
побачимо багато ононь і багато приємних
новин від кожного з наших партнерів Я
наприклад точно знаю навіть в яких тому
будемо намагатись тримати всіх курсів і
дуже Ще раз вам дякую
колеги будь ласка ще хвилинку уваги Дуже
дякую всім спікерам Отже в нас
починається перерва протягом неї ви
можете скористатися кейтерингом після
кейтерінгу все одно запрошуємо вас на
шоу-рум освітніх інновацій повертаємося
сюди всі в 13 і 45 тут буде в нас
дискусія про дебюрокретизацію в
управлінні освітою потім про е-е
застосунки в освіті вивчаю Не чекаю
загалом про інструменти digitalалізації
в освіті А ще після цього в нас буде
супер класний майстер-клас і лейо
Філіпом із представником відгугла тому
будь ласка Ми вас Запрошуємо ми просимо
вибачення за технічні незручності так
буває але я думаю що це буде стимулом
всім зайти на портал дія освіта і
подивитися все-таки це відео принаймні Я
це зроблю чекаємо вас дякуємо
повертаємося 13:45
[оплески]
чого вкрав мій мікрофон
вітер
ти тут
мікрофон виключим мікрофон
мікрофончик
сцену нашу панель цифрової трансформації
діджиталізації поки ми чекаємо допоки
прийдуть всі люди Я хочу сказати що наш
заступник Міністра Дмитро Завгородній
наголошував на тому що в нас є 5
ключових стратегічних цілей над якими ми
працюємо і одна з них Це є ціль по де
бюрократизації освітнього процесу І
власне наші наступні спікери розкажуть
вам покажуть презентації покажуть На
конкретних прикладах і кейсах як ми вже
працюємо над де бюрократизацією в освіті
ми знаємо що освітяни дуже очікують цієї
історії про те шлях є дійсно непростим
бо він потребує багато ресурсів як
людських так і матеріальних потребує
багато внесення змін до
нормативно-правової бази Але тим не менш
ми над цим працюємо тому нас дуже
активно В цьому плані підтримують наші
партнери Швейцарія швейцар
швейцарсько-український проект Дизайн
тому Ми запрошуємо до слова до
презентації про де бюрократизацію
управління освітнім процесом Валентину
Полторак менеджерку
швейцарсько-українського проекту Decide
а після неї зі своєю презентацією
виступить Ксенія лівако це експертка
офісу ефективного регулювання а також
проекту dside будь ласка пані Валентино
вам сцена
оцей це працює
Ну що ж нічого О зараз я себе також чую
колеги дуже рада всіх вітати у нас
сьогодні дуже цікава панель насправді
цікава в першу чергу для управління для
тих хто сьогодні формує нові процеси
управлінські процеси в освіті для всіх
тих хто дотичний до реформи цифровізації
Я би хотіла розпочати з такого промовіду
тому що ми сьогодні по суті презентуємо
оновлену версію і кому це єдина база
даних в освіті але вона тепер буде
функціонувати також як такий ресурс в
якому всі управлінці знайдуть для себе
важливу аналітичну інформацію важливі
додатки і функції які знадобляться на
щодень Ну що ж я не буду розказувати все
що буде відео давайте спочатку
подивимося відео а потім обговоримо що ж
нового ми для вас підготували прошу
включить відео
[музика]
Ну що ж Дорогі колеги ви вже зрозуміли
Мабуть що нас чекає з вами дуже багато
змін І ці зміни починаються у жовтні але
триватимуть протягом багатьох років Я
одразу скажу що всі ці зміни наш проект
швейцарсько-український проект десант і
колеги з Міністерства освіти і науки
разом командному будемо забезпечити їх
стали впровадженням Я прошу включити мою
презентацію готова розказати вам більш
детально про що ж ми будемо сьогодні
говорити Отже
дебюракратизація управління освітою таке
складне слово ми сьогодні багато
говорили на першій панелі На центральній
сцені про управління про менеджмент про
те що без управлінців здійснити будь-які
зміни в освіті неможливо тому наш
продукт Він власне саме для управління
це таке цифрове рішення з яким ви вже
працювали але сьогодні ми презентуємо
його оновлену версію яка повністю
перезібрана і яка запрацює фактично
більш ефективно і буде вашим щоденним
помічником у управління освітою як в
громадах як в регіонах так і для
Міністерства освіти на національному
рівні Ми розпочали ініціативу до
бюрократизацію управління освітою разом
з міністерством освіти і науки України
разом з міністерством цифрової
трансформації ще у 21-му році на той
момент ми проаналізували скільки
управлінці щодень що рік обробляють
звітних документів Ну якщо підсумувати
то тільки звітних документів які
врегульовані подача яких врегульована
нормативною базою ми їх нарахували 53 ми
вже не не говоримо про ті листи які
щодня ви обробляєте на які ви даєте
відповідь центральним органам виконавчої
влади Я впевнена що за рік їх
накопичується сотні для того щоб
зменшити навантаження на вас ми
започаткували цю ініціативу людей і в
тому щоб ваше навантаження скоротилось
на 75% до 25-го року це така дуже
амбітна мета дуже амбітна ціль але
фактично сьогодні вже третій рік нашої
роботи ми можемо говорити про те що ця
ціль вона досяжна Отже що вас чекає ну
по-перше електронне діловодство та про
яке сьогодні вже говорили говорив
міністр говорив віце-прем'єр і на
сьогоднішній день в цифровому форматі ви
можете подавати 14 видів
різноманітних документів які стосуються
діловодства ми розраховуємо що з
наступного року Все діловодство буде уже
оцифроване цей перехід будем яким він
буде супроводжуватись тренінгами
навчаннями звичайно ми не кинемо вас в
цю річку і ви не будете вчитися плавати
там таким шляхом ми будемо
супроводжувати кожен ваш крок в цьому
процесі будемо разом з вчитися і
переходити на електронне діловодство в
школах на рівні територіальних громад
відділах освіти і також в обласних
державних адміністраціях окрім того ми
запланували для всіх абсолютно
учасників освітнього процесу можливість
скористатися послугами в дії
електронними послугами тобто раніше в
нас було безліч паперових документів
Запитів заяв на сьогоднішній день ми
говоримо про те що в дії мають бути
доступні всі дані для батьків для того
щоб вони могли Власне кажучи натиснувши
одну кнопку перевести дитину в інший
заклад освіти відрахувати
зарахувати міг директор ну Власне кажучи
це все-таки взаємопов'язаний комплекс
дій все набагато складніше і включає в
себе набагато більший перелік функцій ми
про це будемо розповідати в жовтні тому
сьогодні такий попередній анонс
Ну і для того щоб дійти висновку що це
дійсно потрібно робити що це на часі В
Україні ми у 21-му році проаналізували
нормативно-правову базу з тих пір ми її
удосконалили І власне про ці зміни в
нормативно-правовій базі буде говорити
наступний спікер Ксенія плювака наша
експертка яка координує цей напрям але
на сьогоднішній день Наша команда разом
з командою Міністерства освіти і науки
працює над тим щоб всі ці зміни вони
нормативно були унормовані і щоби на
рівні громади на рівні школи у жодного
керівника не було ніяких проблем не було
подвійного документа обігу це дуже
важливо
з чого ж складається
iGO ну Власне кажучи у нас були реєстри
до того але всі ці реєстри мали
неверифіковану інформацію і фактично ці
реєстри були перезібрані на сьогоднішній
день ми говоримо що в нас уже є модуль
обліку дітей
є модуль обліку закладів освіти є модуль
обліку співробітників тобто педагогічних
не педагогічних працівників закладів
освіти Також у нас буде доступний жовтня
модуль діловодства це електронні журнали
електронні щоденники на які кожен заклад
освіти має перейти ми знаємо що в
Україні вже дуже багато шкіл вже обрали
оцей цифровий шлях в діловодстві Але
разом з тим що дуже багато бояться
подвійного подвійного заповнення
електронних журналів тому з жовтня
місяця ми також запускаємо цикл
тренінгів і консультації які допоможуть
більш плавно перейти на електронне
діловодство фінансовий модуль фінансовий
модуль він буде доступний з
24-го року цей модуль власне він
покликаний допомогти керівникам відділів
освіти управління освіти територіальних
громад зрозуміти з чого ж складається
формула освітньої субвенції
зрозуміти які відсоток використаних
коштів є по різних видах державних
субвенцій на освіту це такі перші
функції але функції цього модулю ми
будемо розширювати він фактично
покликаний дати швидку інформацію
кожному управлінню про витрати на освіту
в територіальній громаді
аналітичний модуль про нього ще буду
говорити більш розлого управляти без
перевірених даних і без аналітики
сьогодні неможливо вік штучного
інтелекту вік-технології нам звичайно з
вами потрібні інструменти які дозволять
робити це більш якісно фактично за ці
три роки разом з управлінцями освітою
різних рівнів фокус-групах ми
напрацювали понад 100 індикаторів
розвитку освіти і Власне вони всі будуть
представлені представлені в аналітичному
модулі які також запрацює в жовтні це
буде така пілотна версія разом з вами ми
будемо його удосконалювати робити таким
чином щоб він дійсно був корисний для
кожного відділу освіти для кожного
управління для Обласної Державної
адміністрації і на національному рівні
Ми віримо що вся ця інформація дозволить
будувати реформи базуючись на
перевірених даних
окрім того у нас запланований сервіс
замовлення документів про освіту і
модуль статистичної звітності Я думаю що
цей модуль він на сьогоднішній день
найбільше хвилює освітніх управлінців
власне ідея скорочення статистичної
звітності вона і буде багато в чому
реалізована за рахунок цього модулю
окрім того для управлінців на кожному
рівні починаючи закладу загальної
середньої освіти далі У нас є відділ і
освіти і або управління освітою
територіальної громади далі у нас
область власне для всіх цих управлінців
всіх цих рівнів у нас буде доступний
кабінет управління
в кожну на кожному рівні управління там
буде свій функціонал це все передбачено
на законодавством Власне кажучи на рівні
територіальної громади управління збуда
бачити всю інформацію по своїм закладам
освіти і розумію що є невеликі
територіальні громади та там де дві
школи три садка і там управління він
знає які в нього контингент він аналізує
його тому що довгий час там працює має
відповідний досвід але більші громади а
зараз у нас тенденція все ж таки на
окрупнення Вони все ж таки мають
користуватися перевіреною інформацією і
ну знаєте прийняття рішень воно має все
ж таки бути побудовано на тому що в усіх
абсолютно документах по-перше інформація
дається верифікована А по-друге на тому
що ти користуєшся аналітикою все це буде
доступне в кабінеті на рівні
територіальної громади на рівні
територіальної громади у нас не
передбачений доступ до сертифікованих
даних багатьох управлінців це цікавить
персоніфіковані дані Вони залишаються в
школі на рівні територіальної громади це
зведені статистичні дані інформація про
мережу це важливо сьогодні йдуть процеси
оптимізації реформа старшої профільної
школи тому планувати управлінці будуть
уже зважаючи на реальну ситуацію яка є в
їх громаді також фінансовий аналітичний
модуль модуль обліку дітей Даш борди з
різноманітною інформацією вони будуть
побудовані таким чином щоб відповідати
потребам конкретної громади
окрім того кабінети будуть і на рівні
департаментів освіти і також у нас
соцслужбі і також звичайно буде кабінет
можна вся ця інформація вона буде
агрегуватися аналізуватись і вже
слугувати для формування державної
політики в сфері освіти це все власне
запрацює у нас жовтня В такому дещо
урізаному форматі але все одно це перша
версія вона вже дасть нам можливість не
витрачати час на те що на раніше
витрачалась дуже багато часу ми навіть
рахували в одному з наших досліджень що
на подачу статистики на підготовку
відповіді на листи управлінці витрачали
до 12 годин на тиждень Уявіть собі
замість того щоб дійсно виконувати свої
функції та розвивати освіту в громаді
розвивати свій заклад освіти Ми
заповнювали папірці наша в тому щоби
вчитель вчив дітей управління на рівні
директора школи я займався своїм
педагогічним колективом впроваджував
освітній реформи А на рівні
територіальної громади управління смавмо
можливість дійсно управляти а не гасити
пожежі Так що це дуже важливий напрям І
власне оцей перехід в цифру і перевірені
дані воно саме забезпечить ці функції і
це власне є мета цього напрямку
освітній онлайн послуги вони вже
розробляються Я би не хотіла зараз про
них говорити так розлогу тому що це
такий досить
тривалий процес Я впевнена що до кінця
цього року і ми вже дізнаємося про такі
перші сервіси в дії але сьогодні ми вже
можемо говорити про те що це буде сервіс
з урахування відрахування переведення
закладу освіти що вже значно полегшить
життя батьків по всій Україні тобто
фактично ми говоримо про сервіс для 9-10
мільйонів українців Ну і звичайно через
війну багато батьків вони не мають
витрачати цей час стоячи в чергах пишучи
папірці тому що ситуація з безпекою В
нас дуже різна в різних регіонах тому
онлайн це такий ну таке підґрунтя для
безпеки наших громадян
аналітичний модуль Я вже про нього
багато говорила Ну тут ви можете
подивитися його перша версія він власне
базується на індикаторах розвитку освіти
їх у нас 7 але ці сім індикаторів вони
включають майже 100 критеріїв це формули
здавалось би це дуже Насправді це дуже
прості речі про які ми всі з вами як
управлінцями знаємо про них в
законодавство власне визначає цю рамку
для того щоб ці індикатори у нас були
обраховані Ну власне це доступність
кадровий потенціал якість освіти
фінансування спроможність системи
управління освітою комфорта безпека і
матеріально-технічне забезпечення все це
буде подано у вигляді графіків карта в
аналітичному модулі буде доступна
гіскарта в мережі територіальної громади
мережі області Ми над нею також працюємо
на рівні області це буде такий дієвий
інструмент для формування зокрема і
мережі старшої профільної школи про яку
про яку власне ми будемо з вами всі
говорити
навчальний рік я впевнена
що ще в нас є цікавого для вас
стратегічне планування Ну що ж проєкт
довгий час займається стратегічним
плануванням в Україні поки що у нас
такий пілотний етап і три роки тому Ми
зрозуміли що даних по освіті Нам
здавалось би Да ми стільки звітних
документів подаємо стільки листів пишемо
але даних про контингент верифікованих
там даних по мережі їх фактично немає
Тобто кожна громада їх у нас яка у нас
була в пілоті вона їх просто знаєте
покрипітьсям збирала по елементам в
своїх громаді дещо опитуваннями і Ми
зрозуміли що інструмент якому він буде
корисним і для стратегічного планування
тому на кожному рівні управління освітою
ми запланували створення такого
освітнього освітнього профілю освітній
профіль буде у закладу освіти у
територіальної громади і у регіону І
власне на цих рівнях ми вже
відпілотували стратегії вони вже є в
чотирьох регіонах це івано-франківська
Полтавська Одеська і Луганська області
Луганська область ви знаєте всі громади
там евакуйовані Але незважаючи на це
управлінці працюють підтримують життя
закладів освіти в онлайні звичайно тут
дуже важливо розуміти також де
знаходяться діти на сьогоднішній день Де
вони навчаються тому таку стратегію Ми
також для колег розробили Я вже говорила
про те що ми з усіма управлінцями будемо
з Жовтня працювати ми розуміємо що це
такі великі революційні нововведення і
не завжди буде часу управлінців та
опанувати це все дуже швидко тому
фактично протягом року ми забезпечимо
лінію технічної підтримки і також
забезпечимо навчання будемо з усіма з
вами зустрічатися в кожному регіоні
будемо зустрічатися онлайн обговорювати
удосконалювати цей інструмент тобто цей
процес він буде максимально інклюзивний
це в цілому про нашу роботу це трирічна
робота тому звичайно за 5 хвилин дуже
важко розказати які тернистий шлях Ми
пройшли але все це для вас для того щоб
ваше щоденна робота була
якіснішою простішою і вона була на благо
освіти і освітнім реформам я дякую
передаю слово Ксенії плевако Ксеня прошу
ви розкажете більш детально
можливо
Він працює працюєш Так
окей окей Всім привіт доброго дня Зараз
А мене попередили за презентацію
я вирішила що я вам сьогодні розкажу
мабуть інформацію яка має допомогти нам
сформувати спільний контекст куди ми
рухаємося в цифровій трансформації
освіти чому ми рухаємося Саме так чомусь
такою швидкістю і яка роль в цьому
всьому власне системи icom
варто почати власне як казала Валентина
якщо це була дуже довго Робота вона
достатньо комплексна і до прикладу щоб
просто взяти якісь папірець взяти якісь
документи і не просто перетворити його в
pdf-ку і покласти в таку ж саму папку як
стоїть на полиці тільки в комп'ютері нам
треба провести дуже багато різних етапів
наприклад аналітична робота яку ми
провели з
різними учасниками освітнього процесу ми
проаналізували всі документи які були в
школі Я сьогодні буду здебільшого
говорити про рівень загальної середньої
освіти тому що ми
власне почали розробку з цього
компоненту бо він для нашої системи буде
центральним і
ми проаналізували всі документи навіщо
вони потрібні які їх функціональне
взагалі призначення так щоб що цей
документ існує для чого він це окрема
робота з архітектором тому що
недостатньо просто створити якусь
центральну систему на рівні Міністерства
освіти Оскільки ми маємо
децентралізовану систему управління в
державі і ми маємо територіальні громади
ми маємо різні міста які можуть мати і
мають свої системи свої власні а я
забула Вибачте чим
Я не подбала про це Вибачте будь ласка
А куди
[музика]
ви я буду я можу махати ви будете мені
гортати бо я не знаю воно щось не працює
нормально Я перепрошую Отже недостатньо
зробити просто якийсь центральний
компонент якусь єдину систему і яку
просто скинути з гори вниз нам треба
врахувати кожну окремо взяту систему яка
використовується на рівні громади або на
рівні регіону і передбачити щоб вся ця
система власне спільно працювала тут ви
бачите я не буду це дублювати Бо у нас
достатньо мало часу але це основні
напрямки цього проекту буде
бюрократизації які Ми займаємося які
включає організаційний Стрім Стрім що
стосується роботи з документами і
організацією взаємодії оцих зовнішніх
систем рішень електронних щоденників
журналів з центральним компонентом це
окремий напрямок роботи з управлінцями
освіти для створення власне інструментів
розуміння Як має виглядати ці кабінет і
Як бачите з оцього всього тут ще є
окремий напрямок по нормативці я буду
про нього детальні говорити власне
технічна розробка тут є не найскладнішим
всі ці історії
до речі Скажіть будь ласка А хто тут
сьогодні є можете будь ласка підняти
руки хто представляє наприклад заклад
освіти або адміністрації закладу освіти
Ага Окей дякую
громадою управління освіти громади
відділу гуманітарні Ого Окей і можна
регіональний рівень
нікого немає департаменти в світові А ну
Та понятно Окей
тоді я просто буду розуміти на Чому
фокусуватися
перше з чого хочу почати це основне це
те що icom
і то якоюсь з яким ми зараз знайоме я
доступно зараз версія це основний
компонент в системі освіти для
дошкільної загальної середньої
позашкільної освіти це система яка ну
зараз адміністрація інститутом освітньої
аналітики це супер важливий компонент
для розуміння зараз
скільки треба нарахувати субвенції це
основна база даних в принципі і для того
щоб ми могли далі працювати і розвивати
свої сервіси Нам потрібно було
вирішувати ключове питання це питання
обробки персональних даних і юридичної
презентації
iGO тому ми внесли зміни в закон України
про освіту і тут на слайді я вирізала
важливий шматок про те що обробка
персональних даних буде здійснюватися
для забезпечення права на освіту і це
дуже важливий момент тому що якщо ми
подивимося на досвід будь-якої
розвинутої країни
досвід Європи досвід досвід країни які
почали це робити ще з 2000-х років
я не буду фокусуватися на тому скільки
часу ми втратили Що ми робимо це умовно
тільки зараз але я хочу сфокусуватись на
іншому що у нас зараз є унікальна
можливість
використовуючи найкращі практики які є у
світі
підібрати нам те що нам підходить
враховуючи наші
нюанси і нашу роботу системи освіти і
власне впровадити лише те що нам
потрібно і не проходити весь цей
еволюційний шлях який проходили умовно
наші колеги тому що в нас просто з вами
фізично не маю часу ось якщо ви
подивитесь на цей слайд основне Ідея
цього всього це те що ми маємо створити
середовище ми це називаємо екосистема
освітніх рішень в якому ми маємо
забезпечити взаємодію різних рівнів
освіти це ключове У нас є два моменти на
які ми над якими працюємо це перше а
якому це перша
але айком вперше має взаємодіяти з
державними реєстрами тому що освіта не
може існувати сферичну вакуумі вона не
буде існувати сферичну вакуумі У нас є
дані які ми можемо пере- використовувати
з інших державних реєстрів і це
найбільша перевага і найбільше
причина чому взагалі ця модернізація
відбувається і завдяки якому рішенню
вона відбувається ми модернізуємо зараз
iGO за допомогою платформи реєстрів Це
рішення Міністерства
електронне рішення Міністерства цифрової
трансформації і
воно працює абсолютно по-іншому ніж
звикли всі всі
освітяни Я дуже шкодую що я не взяла
дуже стрьомний слайд Я не передбачила що
буде такий великий екран але це
достатньо проста історія насправді вона
все виглядає і є набагато складнішим а
тут просто щоб ви розуміли Як це має
працювати І як ми маємо оці всі
компоненти які зараз у нас є Оці там 100
500 різних рішень
поєднати в одну екосистему щоб воно
працювало і обмінювалось даними а й комп
ось тут Ми побачити всі компоненти які
Валентина власне перелічили вже і у нас
є інша система це є де або власне
управлінці хто тут присутні Вони
працюють в цій системі і в цій системі і
для того щоб це все разом працювали ми
маємо звести цю історію в якійсь
спільний кабінет
він цього
нагадаємо ми зараз говоримо про загальну
середню освіту але тримаємо в голові що
нас ще дошкільна і позашкільна освіта ці
всі історії у нас мають
збиратися в одній центральній базі даних
при цьому у нас з вами є зовнішні
системи і рішення типу дежурного
і ще багато інших про які є детальніше
скажу і ці рішення вони також мають бути
вписані в цю картинку щоб воно все разом
працювало і ми не мали з вами умовно
імпортувати експортувати якісь дані
передавати не дай боже персональні дані
через пошту ukr.net Gmail чи щось там
таке ось тому власне для того щоб це все
працювало Ми
почали роботу з державними реєстрами тут
ви бачите всі які у нас є в законі Про
освіту з якими ми будемо працювати поки
що у нас тестова інтеграція з дратсом
12 тому що
Ну в принципі наша цільова аудиторія
діти вони поки що є тільки в цьому
реєстрі і потенційно Наступного року ми
хочемо вже переключитись на ЄДР тому що
обсяг даних які там є про особу про
кожного з вас в залі він там значно
ширший тобто він включає не тільки
персональні дані там про стать вік тату
народження піп А ще там місце реєстрації
проживання і додаткові параметри які ми
з вами і так використовуємо власне в
діловодстві
[музика]
важлива штука для чого нам оця вся
історія потрібна для того щоб у нас
нарешті
запрацювала оце історія я
колись Дмитро Завгородній запросив мене
займатися цим проектом Перше про що ми
подумали що треба нарешті зробити
національний облік дітей який не буде
фокусовано виключно в освіті в руках
освіти тому що освіта Вона
компетентна зовсім за інший ряд питань а
не за пошук дітей не там ходіння по
вулицям як це раніше було або типу там
вияснення стосунків з батьками і так
далі для цього щоб це вся історія
працювала нам недостатньо одної бази
даних з освіти Нам потрібно більше даних
більше даних які ми вже володіє держава
і вони нам доступні власне ми почали з
реєстру драцс тому що там за стільцем
дитина може ви її не бачите але вона при
народженні потрапляє
отримає свій перший документ в житті -
це свідоцтво про народження і ми поки що
завдяки цьому свідоцтву про народження
це буде один з ключових ідентифікаторів
для нас поки ми не зробимо загальний
освітній ідентифікатор вона потрапляє
уже через драцвейком Тобто войком їм не
потрібно вносити руками цю інформацію
яка вже доступна в інших реєстрах І
власне ідея заключається в тому що ми
будемо перевернути різні набори даних з
доступних нам реєстрів і це не
потребуватиме від нас збирати за людей
якісь там Документи
змушувати батьків давати про себе там не
знаю якісь документи які нам потрібно
буде вносити в інтерфейс Тому це дуже
важливий компонент всі ці історії нас
насправді нас підтримали над соцслужба в
цій історії тому що ми домовилися що ми
розподілимо нашу відповідальність між
обома гравцями для того щоб завдяки
айкому у нас була можливість і зводи ти
статистичну звітність І власне
мати хоч якусь інформацію про те скільки
у нас умовно там в громаді є дітей
шкільного віку і Скільки з них у нас
навчається в наших закладах або в інших
закладах інших громад або міст тому що
icom
Я зараз до нього повернусь тому що суть
айкому в тому що ми робимо єдину
платформу у якій у нас
з'являється можливість робити
онлайн-сервіси зарахування відрахування
переведення між різними закладами різних
міст сіл громад і це суперкласне тому що
якби ця річ запрацювала до повна
масштабного вторгнення
Ви не уявляєте наскільки нам було б
легше вирішити зараз ці питання з даними
дітей які втрачені треба було шукати цих
дітей Ми про зуміли де вони є Ми
зрозуміли нам би не потрібно було
супер колосальна робота інституту
аналітики Для попередньої субвенції тому
що там у цієї гігантські набори даних
які вони просто опрацьовували для того
щоб
зменшити Чи це там окупована до
окупована територія чи є там ці діти
цього б не потрібно було Тому що ми мали
можливість вивести цю статистику на
підставі персональних даних тому це
скрін з нашої тестової версії яку ми
обрабовували з різними закладами освіти
різних областей якщо нас дивляться в цих
ваших інтернетх Я дуже хочу подякувати
всім всім вчителям всім адміністратором
адміністрації закладів освіти всім
управлінцям громад які
інвестували свій час інвестували свої
знання і допомагали на фокус групах
допомагали з відповідями на питання які
допомогли нам власне прийти до певних
усвідомлень тому що ця система Вона може
запрацювати виключно в тому випадку якщо
вона буде
прийнята з рівня первинних даних
базового рівня з рук користувачам а не
опущено з гори
не буду на цьому зупинятися стосовно
нормативки
тут Я не буду це все вам зачитувати бо
це все дуже довго я думаю що презентація
буде доступна але якщо коротко То нам
прийшлось опрацювати
купу купу різних документів в яких ми
перетинаємося в процесах icom тобто якщо
ми говоримо про зарахування то означає
що нам треба переписати або внести зміни
в порядок з урахування відрахування
переведення в закладах освіти якщо ми
говоримо про облік дітей нам треба
змінити 684 Постанову нарешті І ми вже
майже на виході з цієї постановою
насправді от тут з планів на 23-й рік
тут ви можете побачити в основному
документи які стосуються електронного
діловодства питання обліку питання
[музика]
ведення обліку не тільки дітей
здобувачів освіти і це важливо тому що
нам потрібні ці кроки для хорошого
старту перед впровадженням на наступний
рік я залишила всю інформацію яка
стосується власне статистичних звітів
тому що після впровадження І після того
як ми зможемо мігрувати базу даних у нас
з'явиться можливість власне зводити цю
інформацію в якийсь звіти
Окей остання
не можу перемкнутися
Окей
в частині електронного діловодства
важливу штуку яку хотіла сказати Так в
мене ще дві хвилини
Як це має працювати дивлячись на ту
схемку яку ви бачили на початку У нас є
заклад освіти він може використовувати
будь-яке з рішення Яке зараз доступне
там на ринку електронний щоденник журнал
і для того щоб спростити цю процедуру і
зробити її максимально доступною і
прозорою і захистити В цьому плані
трошки освітян Ми беремо на свою сторону
перевірку цих зовнішніх систем ми
зробили власне документи які були на
попередньому слайді це наказ який
регулює порядок доступу до айкому це
наказ який вносить в юридичну площину
визначення що таке електронний класний
журнал і я про це ще буду говорити в
кінці І власне як це має працювати у нас
зараз по сусідству тут є Наші всі
партнери представники освітніх
інформаційних систем там за стіночку
якщо не були то сходить Подивіться
Кожна з цих систем має рішення яке має
різні технічні характеристики
вони подають заявку на підключення до
центрального компоненту Ця
процедура перевіряється Вона має певний
алгоритм перевірки там треба мати
обов'язково каса з її треба відповідати
певному мінімальному набору даних які
нам цікавить і ще там багато параметрів
І власне коли ми свого боку а прогнемо
підтвердимо цю заявку і зрозуміємо що
вона відповідає нашим вимогам ми можемо
дати доступ до центрального компоненту
системи
сьогоднішнього дня урочисто завдяки
титанічному зусиллям в тому числі
інституту аналітики нас тепер є
двосторонній обмін тобто ці системи як і
віддають нам інформацію про зарахування
відрахування Вибачте про відвідування і
про Так ми їм назад можемо віддати
інформацію про їх учнів
нюанс в тому що це виключно учні
конкретного закладу освіти тобто от
на схемі я показала спеціально що от у
нас є кілька рішень зараз насправді їх
підключено 3 І власне
це ті рішення і освітні системи які
зараз уже прийшли перевірку і вони мають
доступ до центральної компоненту
iGO і умовно кожен заклад освіти може
вибрати одну з цих трьох і бути
впевненим в тому що вони прийшли
перевірку вони відповідають
дійсності Світлана новина дивиться Там
Окей і відповідають дійсності Вибачте
відповідають умовам і у випадку якщо ви
захочете перемкнутися з одного рішення
на інше дані які ви будете передавати
вони будуть збережені тобто суть в тому
що ми маємо створити цю буферну зону в
яки ми зберігаємо всі дані і ви були
впевнені що умовно якщо ви завтра
підключите систему то прийдете на роботу
то не буде таких історій коли ваших
даних ніде немає і дивіться як багато
інших партнерів які зараз
приходять процедуру підключення Тобто ви
можете уявити собі масштаб правда як у
нас це вся історія розгортається як
багато зацікавлених бізнесів в тому щоб
боротися за свого користувача робити
якісь цікаві сервіси і
ми заралізмом я зроблю короткий спойлер
на Валентина вже трошки заспоїла ми
будемо починати роботу з
Жовтня уже по впровадженню і
тут важливий момент що ми зможемо
як це правильно сказати
ми зможемо
отримати Ну ми зможемо отримати
інтерфейс власне Ні не Вибачте не те
хотіла сказати задумалась про освітні
Інформаційні системи і все заловив
вилітало але загалом це дуже велика
кількість учасників це дуже круто що
Кожен з них має різних функціонал Тобто
ми за релізуємо ще нову версію сайту
нікому на якому у нас уже є порівняльна
таблиця усіх підключених рішень і ви
зможете їх подивитися і порівняти по
різному категоріям які
які охоплюють в принципі основний
функціонал це означає що хтось з цих
рішень може мати щось у себе там екстре
наприклад інтерфейсу для психологів
хтось може не мати і оце все в принципі
дуже гнучка історія і я сподіваюся що їх
буде більше
да час Все я все в принципі про
електронний класний журнал останні
хотіли сказати Що Оце підключення
зовнішніх систем до центрального
компоненту і їх збільшення воно
привело нас до наступного кроку що от ми
зробили наказ в якому ми визначили що
таке електронний класний журнал а в
наступному наказі ми вже визначимо якусь
дату X яка буде скоріш за все наступного
року
по переходу з паперового електроду
діловодства і
змінимо трошки структуру журналу багато
не буде зараз розказувати Приходьте на
конференцію в жовтні там все розкажемо
більш детально все дякую вам дуже
[оплески]
колеги Дякуємо дуже нашим спікером нашим
партнерам швейцарсько-українському
проекту не можемо тут не згадати
інститут освітньої аналітики який власне
є ключовим органом нашим підпорядкованим
який взагалі створив айкон завдяки якому
iGO функціонує і Збирається вся ключова
освітня статистика є аналітика Дякуємо
вам ми трошки запізнюємося тому ми
переходимо до наступної наступної
презентації інструментів в освіті а саме
застосунку вивчаю Не чекаю і Я запрошую
на сцену Олену Онищенко лідерку проекту
вивчаю Не чекаю в Україні а також
Віктора Ткача це вчителя початкових
класів разом з діточками колеги вітайте
це ми а мене звуть Олена Онищенко я щиро
рада привітати всіх тут
знайди мені міжнародних партнерів І
власне якщо можна переключити на
наступний слайд
Я тут лише заради того щоби розповісти
що
з цієї знаменної трійки яка працює над
цим проектом який присвячений тому щоби
в
початковій школі можна було також
Навчатися або використовуючи цей Tool
або
офлайн Або зовсім онлайн або
використовують в обидвох режимах і я
насправді Я представляю цю середню
червону Ланку
і але є лише одною з трьох ланок які
працюють над цим проектом власне це все
що я хотіла сказати Тому що набагато
більше за мене набагато цікавіше за мене
вам про це розкаже наша група
високоповажних експертів І зараз я хочу
запросити головного експерта п Вікторе
Ткача викладача навчальної школи А разом
з його групою експерт експертів паном
тимофієм прошу оплесків паном Єгором і
панною Вікою
Всім доброго дня
дякую Я думаю ви можете пройти сісти
Всім доброго дня Мене звати Віктор Ткач
я вчителем початкових класів напевно не
тільки за професією за покликанням Ну
якось так сталось Що з 8 класу
захотілось бути вчителем я тут
Цього року я працюю вчителем початкових
класів та менеджером з освітніх проектів
початкової школи в мрії School І
сьогодні ми тут щоб презентувати
освітній застосунок вивчає Не чекаю
зараз я попрошу наших дітей сісти бо я
буду трішки говорити А вас буде
можливість подосліджувати додаток без
мого суперника
дякую
Отже
безоплатний мобільний застосунок
інтерактивного навчання вивчає Не чекаю
містить в собі пізнавальний та освітні
матеріали які розроблені підходами
мікронавчання
дитина може досліджувати навчальну
програму з мови і математики подивилась
цікаве відео в кінці за допомогою
міні-гри може закріпити навчальний
матеріал
цікавим є те що наш застосунок повністю
відповідає чинним вимогам законодавства
та програмовим вимогам нуж Тобто його
можна спокійно інтегрувати в навчальний
процес і використовувати як повноцінну
навчальну програму так і інтегрувати у
свій навчальний процес щоб робити
навчання більш цікавим
додаток можна застосунок можна
використовувати вдома в школі або
дистанційно тобто все залежить від
фантазії вчителя якщо вчитель хоче
використати на уроці це як частину уроку
як повністю урок як лише інтегрувати
дати насам підготовку наприклад Чи як
домашні завдання тут Свобода вчителя
можна використовувати індивідуальну або
з цілим класом Я зазвичай наприклад коли
в мене є індивідуальна робота з учнями в
демонструє екран і Ми прекрасно
повторюємо певну тему за допомогою
міні-ігор зашить за своїми матеріалу
застосунок можна використовувати в
Україні і в будь-якій точці світу і
важливим є те що достатньо лише раз
завантажити пакетні дані які ви сам
застосунок вам запропонує наприклад з
мови чи читання і далі застосунок буде
повністю доступний без
інтернет-з'єднання тобі ж Наприклад ми
живемо зараз суворих реаліях будь-який
момент повітряна тривога ми спускаємося
в сховище діти беруть гаджети якщо і
досліджують мову чи читання самостійно
або вже з допомогою вчителя беремо
виходимо із ситуації Тобто ми можемо
використовувати і тут як можемо
на кожному уроці математики та читання
доступні відео та міні-ігри які
допомагають засвоїти програмовий
Матеріал у повному обсязі тобто
застосунок нас для учнів і від першого
до четвертий клас відповідно кожна тема
затронута її можна використати на
будь-якому етапі навчального року і на
будь-якому принципі етапи уроку
під час самого навчання і використання
нашого навчального застосунку дітей
супроводжують віртуальні герої різних
професій які допомагають навчатися це
вчена поліцейська
президент програміст тощо наші головний
герой з математики - це Софійка з
читання Це Андрійко який допомагають нам
досліджувати Ці предмети а з іншими
героями Наші учні знайомляться поступово
протягом самого навчального процесу
Досліджуючи
і їхні професії допомагаєте допомагаючи
їм
покращувати їх будинки там отримати
різні сувеніри Тобто застосунок повністю
геміфікований для початковому для
початкової школи можна використовувати
від А до Я зараз ми вам презентуємо урок
математики який ви можете з інтегрувати
у свій навчальний процес це була така
невеличка його міні-частина лише для
того щоб надихнути і вам як можна
використати що з яких імені Ігор
складається наш застосунок так тема з
математики віднімання додавання
двоцифрових чисел частинами звичайно
чекаю наші учнів вже тут вони
переглянули зараз відео разом з нами
сподіваюсь зараз має звук піти в
навушники
а діти відкривають урок номер два і у
відео номер два друзі Усім привіт привіт
Сьогодні ми з вами пригадаємо різні
способи додавання та віднімання чисел
частинами наприкінці уроку ви зможете
обрати для себе той який буде
найзручнішим почнімо з додавання але
спочатку пригадаємо як називаються
компоненти і результат дії додавання
чудово перший доданок другий доданок
сума додамо до двоцифрового числа
одноцифрове розглянемо вираз 27 + 4 для
того щоб обчислити вираз першим способом
потрібно подати другий доданок чотири у
вигляді суми зручних додатків так щоб
число 27 Доповнити До круглого числа -
це числа три та один після чого нам
потрібно до 27 додати 3
вже потім до результату який утворився
це число 30 додати ще один Так ми
одержимо число 31 існує ще один прийом
обчислення цього ж виразу це можна
зробити на основі правила додавання
числа до суми для цього Нам необхідно
розкласти перший доданок число 27 на
розрядні доданки 20 та сім далі одиниці
додаємо до одиниць 7 + 4 = 11 після чого
до 20 додаємо одержаний результат це
дорівнюватиме також 31 перейдемо до
додавання двоцифрових чисел яке містить
також кілька способів для розрахунку ми
візьмемо числа 27 та 34 подивимося
уважно на другий спосіб
Спочатку я пропоную розкласти другий
доданок число 34 на розрядні доданки а
саме на 30 та 4 після чого необхідно до
числа 27 спочатку додати число 30 і до
одержаної суми ще додати число 4 у
результаті обчислення ми одержимо число
61 щоб зрозуміти як працює другий спосіб
варто запам'ятати що другий доданок
потрібно розкласти на зручні доданки до
прикладу число 34 розкладаємо на три та
31 Спочатку я до числа 27 додаю три а
потім до результату число 31 значення
виразу буде також результат 61 друзі
Отже в цьому відео ми розглянули два
способи додавання чисел частинами
а також спосіб порозрядного додавання
запам'ятайте що для того щоб додати
число частинами необхідно обране число
подати у вигляді суми розрядних або ж
зручних доданків після чого по черзі
додати одержані результати
Тобто ми можемо побачити що сучасне
оформлення гарне пояснення підкріплене з
картинкою в принципі для наших сучасних
дітей є дуже актуальними наші діти Зараз
більше в частині візуали які люблять
першим це все побачити вони оцінюють
картинку а потім думають Чи цікаво Це
нам насправді навіть тут стоявши біля
наших трьох дітей серед вибірки взяти
картинку подивитися відео двоє з них уже
грали далі
тобто слухаємо і вже за свою матеріал
далі проходячи наступні завдання і так
будемо вас навчальних класах коли ви
дасте наприклад завдання хто з його вже
виконає це про індивідуалізації говорить
а хтось уже піде наперед і буде
досліджувати далі і в цьому також плюс
нашого застосунку Оскільки тут
індивідуалізує навчальний процес під
кожного учня і є можливість надолужити
так само і освітні втрати і плюс
використати як індивідуально так і гру-
групові завдання Отже діти Я зараз
попрошу вас Відкрити другий урок відео
номер чотири там гра буде вас четверта
аби в свою чергу зможете поспостерігати
за тим що виконують діти тобто це
приклад
міні-гри на засвоєння теми віднімання
додавання двоцифрових чисел частинами
я можу
А ми з вами позмагаємося хто перший
виконав це завдання
[музика]
діти проводяться ігри швидше ніж
дорослий Це запис умовно екрану який я
вчора проходив дорослий діти вже прийшли
І це допомагає так само ви бачите в нас
наприклад є другий урок вже Восени ми
презентуємо посібник для вчителів вам
зараз допомагаю такі як міні екземпляри
першого уроку восени буде повний
посібник тобто вчитель залишається
Наприклад взяти готовий і використати
під час свого уроку або ж на звороті там
методичного листка є qr-код де можна
відсканувати його і безпосередньо наша
Мирослава Коба розкаже вам як можна
створювати уроки інтегруючи навчальні
застосунок Так дякую діти тепер шосте
відео поз можна побачити да шосте
від числа у межах 100
Використай для виконання завдання
стовпчики десятки та Куби одиниці щоб
спочатку відняти десятки потім
[музика]
синхронність тут зашкалює просто
однаково з однаковою синхроністю
завершили відео ми можемо бачити що по
кожному уроці є різноманітні міні-ігри
тобто на першому плані є відео які коли
ти перший раз дивишся їх скибнути не
можна тобто дитина його передивиться
тобто є пояснення яке складене
методистами озвучено наш нашими героями
які допомагають супроводжують наше
навчання під час використання застосунку
повністю пройшли урок лише потім
відкривається наступний тобто принцип
наступності тут теж збережено вже можна
з 1 вересня в принципі інтегрувати це
все в навчальній процес ну скажемо так
не першого давайте з четвертого вихідні
там ще будуть
частина з вас вже отримали методичні
такі посібники як прикладах хтось
сьогодні був на міні-майстерці буквально
тут За ширмою де ми розповідали так в
усій формі про застосунок як його можна
використати тому подібне хто ще не
отримав свій примірник можна зайти за
стенд після закінчення нашої майстерки і
отримати ми можемо там повідповідати на
запитання в кого виникли важливо тут є
qr-коди Де ви можете доєднатися до
вчительської спільноти де будуть
приблизні дати реліза або конкретні дати
релізу оновлені які ви можете
використовувати вже під час навчального
процесу також є qr-код як
ви можете побачити qr-код Ось він є це
проти вебінар який я говорив на початку
тобто вже можна створювати свої щоб не
чекати готових уроків вже можна
створювати свій свої уроки інтегрувати
їх навчальний процес
уже наразі наш застосунок доступний на
App Store і Google Play Так само восени
планується запуск на дископну версію до
Windows тобто вчитель може використати
безпосередньо на уроці просто включивши
в себе на екрані через шнур вивести на
дошку умовно або під час онлайн уроку чи
офлайн навчання тобто все залежить від
фантазії вчителя тож запрошую вас
відсканувати наш qr-код за яким ми вже
Можете завантажити додаток
досліджуватись світ математики і мови
разом з нами бо читання це є
інтегрований курс мови і читання це
важливо
і робити навчальні цікавим я дякую вам
за увагу діліться застосунком своїми
колегами особисто в мене вже племінники
користуються навіть перший другий клас
але вже я просто поділюся тим яка є
освіта в сільській школі ви розумієте Да
там через тиждень вони ходять А це все
закриває освітні потреби навіть навіть
сказати там тому Дякую вам
запрошую на майстер-клу Можливо будуть
запитання За ширмою там є наш стенд ми
дякую дітям
колеги дякую за таку цікаву презентацію
Я не знаю Як там ваші племінники Я так
само собі завантажила додаток І деколи І
деколи залипаю на нього дуже цікаво Отже
колеги ми до 15:30 маємо обід Так що
можете видихнути можете бути спокійними
і йдемо обідати А потім о 15:530
вертаємося на майстер-клас і лі Філіпова
і представника компанії Google про
штучний інтелект в освіті Ми дуже
дякуємо що ви з нами Ми сподіваємося що
вам цікаво Ми дуже старалися для вас
після того як обіг пообідаєте Запрошуємо
вас на шоу-рум освітніх інновацій
гарного обіду смачного
[музика]
що ви хочете зробити це власне навчатись
і не витрачати менше часу на
нудні складні адміністративні завдання
які звісно важливі але часу на них
витрачати не хоче ться тож які є
приклади
в нас є вже в бета доступі в нашій
технології для класних кімнат можливість
багато робити
аналітичної роботи
Можете наприклад подивитися як ваші
студенти
як
який результат не показують по шкільній
програмі можете зробити висновок Як ваш
вчитель там Джонні чи Дмитро більш такий
типово українське ім'я і чи він зможе
взагалі пройти цей курс і багато іншої
такої аналітики
це не є доступним сьогодні в класній
кімнаті Для кожного це такі включені
завдання Але це буде доступно на
найближчими майбутньому наступним
прикладом може бути я не знаю скільки з
вас використовую YouTube для освітніх
цілей але багато тих викладачів по
всьому світі вони використовують і
використовують як додатковий продукт і
напевно використовується YouTube як
більше аніж інший платформи але те що
сьогодні є це можливість в аудиторії в
ста представляти інтерактивні
заняття і ми використовуємо штучний
інтелект
запропонувати такі запитання які б могли
б запитати студенти в базуючись на
змісті знову ж таки
ви не треба цього лякатися і якщо ми
подивимось на роки вперед І до речі є
багато-багато інших прикладів того як ми
вже вбудовуємо все більше і більше
технології штучного інтелекту щоб
зарядити
продуктивність наших викладачів Давайте
поговоримо про те як почуваються
студенти як вони можуть навчатися в
майбутньому з штучним інтелектами і
технологіями штучної інтелекту і якщо
про вчителів йдеться про продуктивність
то для студентів це
більше йдеться про персоніфікацію
навчання
індивідуалізацію і недалекому
майбутньому у нас буде така риса
характерна яка буде доступною це
частина Google Classroom яка
використовується для освіти А на жаль
досі не є доступною в Україні але е
практика її є дуже цікавою Я працюю в
освітніх технологіях вже близько 18
років і обіцяв обіцянки були такі що це
буде можливість для студентів мати більш
індивідуалізароване навчання але на
практиці ми вже починаємо це
використовувати за допомогою технології
штучного і інтелекту студенту може бути
представлена
добірка завдань і можуть бути такі
завдання і які будуть запропоновані
конкретно конкретна учні або студенту
с послуговуючись його власними рисами і
тобто вчитель
так може навчатись навчатися більш
повільно чи більш такою технологією
студент може рухатись вперед зі своєю
власною швидкістю відповідно до його
характерних рис Так це не є ще доступною
технологією в Україні але
найближчим часом Можливо вона стане
ефективною
вчителі не мають лякатися того як
вживати ці технології
найбільш відома технологія
і вона зараз є доступною для широкого
загалу Ми називаємо це
продукт для
споживача і я сподіваюсь що є такі
страхи що
можливо це не буде
можливим для студента для навчання Ага і
ми маємо такі це непокоєння що можливо
студенти будуть використовувати цю
технологію для написання есе чи
письмових робіт і це
турбує викладачів я висловлю своє власне
свою власну думку що ми інколи більше
Хвилюємось аніж це потрібно робити Я
пам'ятаю як як технології були
задіяні в освіті і весь час ми
хвилювалися про це Я не кажу що не треба
бути обережним Але я пам'ятаю коли
вчителі говорили ви маєте навчатися цієї
складної математики оскільки а не треба
цього навчатися тому що у нас є
калькулятор який рахує але подивиться
Наразі у нас у всіх є калькулятори і
тобто блокування студентів від Вживання
таких продуктів як чи це буде складним і
я вважаю що найкращою стратегією буде
подумати як використовувати ці
технології
як зробити живим освіту
ми вважаємо
коли ми розробляємо ці технології ми
вважаємо що вони будуть доступними
і
вони будуть включати деякі функціональні
реси такі як
допомагати у написанні текстів
продуценуванні текстів і можливо будуть
мати можливості такі ви зможете
візуалізувати слайди і описувати яким
чином це може бути визуалізовано І це
дуже цікава я не можу дочекатися коли
вчителі студенти зможуть використовувати
це в якості частини своєї креативних
завдань
і я думаю що можливості вони є
неймовірними і вони більш неймовірні
аніж та шкода якої вони можуть
завдати Я не впевнений що всі з цим
погодяться і останній приклад Це може
допомогти вам організувати дані Google
shit скільки з вас е-е витрачали багато
часу намагаючись зрозуміти що саме там
треба зробити в Google Shape І що саме
із технологіями штучного інтелекту ви
будете в змозі комунікувати з вашим е-е
SHAREit і робити це з і це буде краще
аніж
і цей інструмент буде більш продуктивний
аніж витрачати багато годин намагаючись
ви навчитися того як це робити І я знаю
що багато викладачів використовували цей
інструмент для планування і знову ж таки
це підвищує продуктивність і знову ж
таки будуть все більше компанії які
розробляють технології штучного
інтелекту і у нас є місце для навчання
для використання макет плейса або випуск
ви зможеш бути в змозі знайти і певні
додатки які можна бути інтегрувати з
Google Space і ми будемо робити це у
відповідальний спосіб якщо
У нас є багато відповідальності про які
ми маємо подумати навіть якщо це
потенційна
позитивна ми маємо
думати про те чи не зашкодить це і не
чекайте що ці характеристики з'являться
прям завтра негайна і я хочу закінчити
що ми вважаємо що осилою технології яке
зможе створити майбутнє коли навчання
буде індивідуалізованим гнучким
доступним і викладачі отримають добрий
час для себе і як технологія компанія
технологіями маємо бути відповідальними
щодо розробки цього щоб це не завдало
школи шкода навпаки підвищила
продуктивність і якщо ви маєте певні
переживання щодо цього сумніви я
хочу сказати що
я
всякий час я використовую це як
початкову Як початок для своєї роботи і
ви можете на початку подумати що
я
я це
я це використовую як певний інструмент
який
напрацьовує
напрацьовує певні малюнки і Я запросив
такий малюнок який би показав українця у
дитину українською Яка замислилась І от
мені запропонував такий малюнок і я з
нетерпінням чекаю про те як освітяни
почнуть використовувати технології
штучного інтелекту і я би хотів вас
надихнути на це я сподіваюсь що ви стали
менше відчувати переживань і страхів
щодо штучного інтелекту Я напевно
витратив набагато часу або Трохи
перебільшив але я хочу подякувати вас за
те що ви слухали мене
і
за цю можливість
мене чутно всім нормально да бо у мене
іноді відходиться штучка
так трішки катастрофи тому що розказати
про використання штучної інтелекту в
освіті за 35 хвилин ну це надзвичайно
складна задача У нас тренінги для
бізнесу тривають шість годин і я хочу я
намагався вмістити максимальний мінімум
який я вважаю потрібний щоб щось
зрозуміти а більше за все зрозуміти
просто
алгоритмічно як і навіщо ми можемо
використовувати
штучний інтелект у світі я вирішив
зупинитися справді на чаті GPT тільки їм
обмежитися швидко просто щоб дати
розуміння логіки і так як я можу навіть
не встигнути прочитати всю презентацію Я
хочу сформувати таке Навіщо для освітян
поки Ну тут була презентація Вільяма я
накидав такі слова про які всі кажуть
але не Всі розуміють як їх що з ними
робити
поговоримо про тренди взагалі загалом
одне один з ефективних я я написав
рандомні штуки просто щоб швидко їх
обговорити одна із ефективних рис освіти
називається льодто трансфер Тобто це
вміння перенести те що ти вивчив одній
дисципліні на іншу дисципліну наприклад
рівняння коливання поплавка на воді у
фізиці можна перенести на базову там
модель соціології коливання коливання
популяції Хижак здобич і коли людина
гарно опанувала якусь концепцію вона
зможе перенести цей і побачити в якісь
іншій дисципліні це перше що повинно
робити одне з тих що повинна робити
ефективна освіта і ось цей
льоттотрансфор якщо ми звертаємося до
штучного інтелекту Він дуже гарно
розуміє саме моделі і це якраз
можливість використати його тут
наприклад як якийсь ефект можна про
спостерігати наведи мені аналогію як її
можна просто спостерігати ще десь І це
дуже гарний інструмент до якого ну
додуматися доволі складно самому коли ми
наводимо аналогії всім відомо що чим
ближча аналогія до того хто сприймає
щось тим краще він це розуміє відповідно
для ваших учнів це можливість
згенерувати багато аналогій це до
прикладу далі Active Learning всі про це
говорять що пасивна форма сприйняття
матеріалу вона не така ефективна як
ефективні форми сприйняття матеріалу
Тобто ви ще слухаєте це не ефективно не
дуже ефективно Якщо прийдете пропрацюєте
це якось обробите пограйте з тим про що
я буду розповідати це буде більш
ефективно отже з точки зору ексіблення у
нас буде дві сторінки прикладів того як
ви можете прямо зараз використовувати з
учнями ці історії щоб формулювати у них
формувати активні задачі прямо на уроках
групові роботи роботи з тим щоб вони
якось обробляли інформацію по-третє
аналітичне мислення в якийсь момент
аналітичне мислення почало у всяких
ворл-економік форумах як навичка
відходити назад але зараз появою
доступних мовних моделей і таких
популярних аналітичне мислення знову
таки виходить на е-е Ну на перші місця і
за допомогою чату вже підійти ми про це
також поговоримо дитина ваша зможе
здобувати таку навичку доволі ефективну
наступне критичне мислення ми про це
будемо говорити мовні моделі гальценують
відповідно якщо галюцинують - це можуть
видавати неправдиву інформацію
відповідно це також може бути як вправи
для розвитку критичного мислення у
дитини якщо ви її розвинете зі штучним
інтелектом і допоможете її зрозуміти що
все треба перевіряти чекати і так
далі що вона буде робити льоту трансфер
в житті буде прикладати це на
соціологічний центр розрахунково далі
персоналізоване навчання це те що
говорять Головне що можна досягти при
використанні
і так далі це на цей доставка чому вона
на це йде звичайно ви знаєте у вас
допустіть
наприклад у вас є 30 учнів з генетики
персоналізовані завдання для 30 людей
доволі складно але ви можете на прикладі
трьох людей у вашій групі а навчити
у вашому чаті розуміти вашу групу і ваш
хід думок при формулюванні завдань і
знову-таки Він непогано працює з
аналогіями це те про що казав Вільям
пришвидшення продуктивності більш
продуктивно ви це швидше зробите швидше
думає На жаль але це точно так далі е-е
інтерпретація результатів це ще один
важливий дуже тренд зараз е-е великий
тренд на те щоб розуміти які саме
метрики потрібно знімати зі студентів у
різних інтерактивних матеріалах
онлайн-курсах і так далі і закладати це
поперед instruction поперед дизайну
інstraction дизайну тобто дизайну
освітнього продукту закладати метрики
якими міряємо і на це зараз на цьому
дуже велику увагу приділяють зйому та
аналізу метрик час шепеті доволі хороший
у фреймворках це вам допоможе зрозуміти
Ну фреймворки як знімається метрики і
тому подібне якщо ви навіть не знаєте
Щось щось ви можете написати Я зібрала
таку-то аналітику зі своїх учнів там не
знаю той швидше засвоює той повільніше
той там ну зібрали якісь числа які ви не
до кінця розуміти як точно
інтерпретувати він може вам допомогти
своїмворком інтерпретації даних або з
пропозицією того які метрики і як
інтерпретувати або які міряти це дуже
потужний інструмент для цього
ну і ще один звичайно дуже потужний
тренд і який наздожене Україну капець як
це інклюзія Daewoo
що вам Ну як Може тут допомогти Ця
історія він ці приборки також розумі
наприклад зробив і текст З гендерної
нейтральним зробив мій текст з
врахуванням інклюзії або з урахуванням
рівності і тому подібне якщо ви
викладаєте свій предмет то вам потрібно
вивчити ще цілу науку про
інклюзію
це велика наука я навчався трішки
буквально два дні в США
найуніверсальному дизайні це Universal
designs це якраз про те і я зрозумів що
це просто ну це велика історія Там під
відмітки текстів до того як воно там
повинно працювати який розмір шрифтів і
тому подібне і тут ви також вже зараз
можете починати робити свої матеріали
більш у цьому стилі а тепер поїхали по
самій лекції скільки в
стигнемось
раз я Якщо вам щось подобається
сфоткайте допомагають потім вдома більш
детально розберетесь бо справді на жаль
не маємо часу на практику і так далі
ідеальна Філіпов з цього фонд-студіо
онлайн освіти думаю що ви про нас багато
знаєте сподіваюсь от ми робимо
інтерактивні освітні продукти 9 років
дуже багато різних
і так я працююча бачите можете запитати
просто в нього Але найголовніше що
потрібно зрозуміти це не штучний
інтелект який навчився і потім ви його
чуть запитали і він просто вам відповів
це мовна модель що це таке Це як ти
дев'ять у вас В телефоні просто більше
нового покоління те воно
передбачене
найімовірніше слово яке буде далі це
означає що він точно
зараз я просто не сам не прочитав але
це означає що він може видавати
неправдиву інформацію Тобто його не
треба використовувати як Google це не
він це мовна моде найбільш ймовірніше
слово далі а не повний факт цілком що це
може означати Наприклад скажи мені з
якого ти там дістав джерела цю
інформацію і він вам згенерить посилання
на якісь там обмету мовний чи нейчер ну
науковий журнал але допише сам просто це
посилання якби найбільш реалістично якби
воно могло виглядати але ви натиснете на
нього і його Такого нема Є такий прикрий
навіть кейс вже у США був кейс про те як
юрист просто написав вирок а потім
сказав
типу Підбери звідки е ці цитування міг
взяти він підібрав а потім був великий
скандал бо не всі цілінки були неробочі
так Нагадую що він найкраще працює
англійською але в принципі Ну для
багатьох задач він вам підійде і
українською і російською швидко біжимо
далі
що ви можете робити швидкогенерувати
чернетки текстів коду
Економія часу і так далі якість
результату залежить від рівня експертизи
користувача Це найголовніше чого не
треба його боятися звільнення багато про
це говорив і тут це криється в
останньому пункті якість результату
залежить від рівня експертизи
користувача а
навряд чи Ну мені так здається
штучний інтелект замінить людину але
людина яка розуміється на штучному
інтелекту точно з великою ймовірністю
може замінити людину яка на ньому не
розуміється бо вона буде просто більш
продуктивною більш професійною і тому
подібне проте ваша експертиза визначає
межі того наскільки експертним буде те
що ви не робите з часом jpg це
інструмент точно так як інтерактивна
дошка Якщо вам повісити в класі
інтерактивну дошку але ви не знаєте як
натискати на неї пальцями ви будете на
ній писати крейдою і це результат буде
ще гірший ніж
що він робить
текст І це напевно
найважливіше аналізувати інформацію
якось її підсумовувати щось не робити
розділяти знову-таки він розуміє як
витягти у якомусь приборку щось для вас
зробити генерує текст і генерує багато
ідей і оце важлива частина ніколи не
видає кінцевий готовий результат по
крайній мірі одразу Так поїхали значить
на цьому слайді Я коротко просто написав
декілька якби ідей що він може що з ним
робити той точно гарно я перестаю себе
чути Зараз Я відійду щоб було видно
і ми зараз пройдемося по деяким ідеям
застосування на прикладі
Так зараз секунду сюди підійду так
і так приклад як асистент
нашій команді часто трапляються
конфлікти Запропонуйте теми тренінгів
які допомогли б вирішити цю проблему ну
написав він
згендрував ідеї різні ідеї далі одразу
вам скажу що він кожен раз генерує різне
на один і той запит Якщо вам мало ідей
Натисніть кнопку Ranger Raid згенерує ще
ідей частина з них може бути зовсім
інвалідними Тому далі валідації ідей ми
даємо йому зворотній зв'язок Мені
подобається ідея тренінгу з емоційного
інтелекту Дякую Дякую Ну обов'язково
писати насправді просто я з ним ввічливо
спілкуюся дуже дивна штука але мені
чомусь так приємно Я не знаю що ти
думаєш про те що підготувати цей тренінг
у форматі асинхронного онлайн-курсу
написав ідею да далі звужуємо щоби нам
щось отримати від нього не просто воду
Да бо багато там ну це вода це і так
зрозуміло і так далі найголовніша
частина в ньому промтингові і тому
подібне це то рамки які ви йому задаєте
ви це робити Таким послідовним чином так
буде працювати краще ніж одразу задати
рамки
підготовка структури заняття Супер дякую
запропоную мені навчальні ціли та
структуру для двогодинного воршопу з
емоційного інтелекту пішли ми вже
звузили дводинний горшок у нас пішов
далі напиши ще й 15хвилинний сценарій
рольової гри для практики емпатії на
онлайн воркшопі бо він там написав що
імпетія буде частиною Окей зроби нам
рольову гру Active Learning іноді нам
складно такі такі речі проробити але вот
для цих активних вправ - це також дуже
гарно працює
а черже піті яка син стенд підготовка
матеріалів заняття так підсумують цей
текст перепиши у конкретну блабла-бла
Так пішли далі буде щоб не втрачати час
А приклад як тренажер англійської мови
зараз буде далі може надати зворотний
зв'язок заданими критеріями Це також
важливо пам'ятайте Я весь час на цьому
наголошую він шарить критерії критерії і
фреймворки це головне що треба
запам'ятати есе по критеріям наприклад
проаналізувати ось в ЗНО є наприклад
критерії УСС він доволі гарно може
справлятися з аналізом по критеріям
тобто уявляєте скрізь де ви можете
проробити якісь критерії він вам може
дуже суттєво пришвидшити вашу роботу
тому дуже важливо вміти вигадувати
критерії і з цим він також може
допомогти так певну роль наприклад коуча
до цього ми також дійдемо привіт ти мій
учитель ісландської вчиш мене розмовляти
іспанською Постав мені одне запитання
іспанської Почекай поки відповім потім
Постав мені наступне запитання коли я
роблю помилки виправляю хто пояснює
вот написав один зрозумів що він вчитель
іспанської він ще не знає який у тебе
рівень в дужках бачите одразу написав і
український переклад хочу Вона його це
не просила робити Ну у нас тут Аватар
міг густонодар і він одразу також
виправляє помилку і пише у скобках там
українською мовою пояснення давайте
оціни все закритеріями оціни СС
попереднього повідомлення за наступними
критеріями відповідність усе концепції
наявність Та чітки це ми спеціально їх
Прописали для прикладів щоб ви розуміли
як можуть виглядати ці критерії і як
можна це використовувати
так якщо не встигаєте То кажіть але я в
принципі запитаю організаторів Хто
захоче я їм віддам презентацію ви
зможете її забрати у нас знає дерево
можете знайти і
тренінг один і ще два курси є для
бізнесу і для освітян Якщо вам буде
цікаво Це далі
поїхали далі допоможи мені поставити
цілі ти професійний Коуч ти допомагаєш
людям досягати їхніх цілей вже 20 років
давай розпочнемо коучингу сесію
Звичайно що замість
знаю справжнього там психотерапевту це
не не найкраща історія але як
себе підтримати коли немає змоги якось
по-іншому то їдемо далі а тепер ці два
слайди просто фотографуйте їх я не буду
дуже сильно зупинятися Дивіться це
Юнеско нещодавно
випустило великий отчёт
щодо можливих найкращих варіантів ну
дієвих варіантів використання Чад GPT
при навчанні людей
тут буде два слайди тут одразу прописано
Ось на запитання Окей як мені його
використовувати
ручні можливостей пропонує альтернативні
способи висловити думку ви можете давати
таке завдання це розвиває там наприклад
перша історія звичайно розвиває там
кругозір розуміння як це працювати І так
далі сократівські опонент це дуже
прикольно працюють для дебатів ми з
друзями доволі часто практикуємо історію
що ми сидимо сперечаємося щодо чогось
наприклад не знаю легалізація
проституції Вот і
ми у освітньому форумі Саме таке навів
але Вибачте але потім ми йому задаємо
контекст кажемо чому ми про це
сперечаємося описуємо нашу країну
описуємо які у нас Люди і тому подібне
вводимо його в контексті пропонуємо його
плюси та мінуси я вам скажу так на
Львові не конференції е-е освіторію у
нас була панель про плюси та мінуси
загрози та плюси використання штучного
інтелекту в освіті і ми оце півтори
години сперечались а потім Мій друг з
залу просто ввів в контекст що
відбувається і попросив його написати ці
плюси мінуси Ну десь на 90% співпали я
вам так скажу А ми там думали сиділи
навіщо непонятно вот наступний слайд
також ще ще трішки методів використання
насправді оце саме те що вони написали
бачите тут прохає радіcation написано
але для мене Ну ці методи вони Ну я не
бачив що вони чисто для харюdecation
проте ви вже Можете прям брати і тупо
завтра спробувати це без всякого страху
там піти в це я розумію як страшно
входити в якусь технологію бо ми
пам'ятаєте запускали колись онлайн-курс
для вчителів початкової школи це було 6
років тому ми по телефону створили 3000
перших поштових скриньків вчителям там
зараз 275 тисяч людей
торг депрессію ми все пам'ятаємо коли
його запустили Я знаю як це складно коли
їх перший раз загнали на ту
онлайн-платформу і тому подібне тому я
дуже прошу вас Візьміть Якусь із цих
штучок просто не вигадуйте чогось
Візьміть і просто Спробуйте і подивіться
на учнів як воно може спрацювати чи
допомагає воно вам чи ні спробуйте так
далі
для чого не варто використовувати
неможливо казати
неможливо казати про жодну технологію не
сказавши як точно не треба її
використовувати
і так не використовуйте її для пошуку не
використовуйте її для розрахунків як
конфіденційної інформації але я потім
скажу Як можна для конфіденційної
інформації ну можна
і для досліджень без фоксікінгу якщо ви
не фокчекаєте це і так
реве та стогне Це початок вірша І знову
збирається на Бій вся Козацька слава
Лесі Українки вірш написаний в 17-му
році він ми йому написали реве та стогне
і він написав нам продовження
реалістично виглядає якщо ви не знали
цього вірша Там просто навчались були б
там школярем ви Ну могли повірити в це
Без проблем тому пам'ятайте що він мовна
модель Ой Так завжди Я повернув би там
побачив що ви фотографуєте це емпатія У
мене така Дякую всьо далі поїхали
так завжди перевіряйте відповідь Він
дуже впевнено бреше далі
як обійти обмеження актуальності до
21-го року там є така Галочка
веб-експрес в викачаєте встановлюєте
розширення вебчак GPT до у нього
з'являється доступ до інтернету і
встановлюєте веп Access не обов'язково
цей інструмент любе аналог такий є я не
скажу що воно буде працювати супер-супер
круто Але воно по крайній мірі скаже що
Росія напала на Україну
повномасштабну і так далі вот бо основна
версія не скаже бо у неї дані до 21-го
року далі налаштування конфіденційності
там є флажок Chat historing Raining ви
можете його прибрати і він не буде
використовувати це для свого загального
навчання
от якщо ви хвилюєтесь за це
будь ласка далі
як складати інструкцію це найголовніша
частина бо від того як Ви це будете
робити залежить багато і я дам декілька
лайфхаків які Вам допоможуть надзвичайно
круто вже зараз почати це робити не
надзвичайно думаю що нам намагатися щоб
ви надзвичайно це було круто сказати
Пром ти - це інструкція для штучного
інтелекту це недосвідчений асистент
якісна інструкція запропонує також що
він зробить все гарно Якщо коротко все
тримається на трьох китах конкретність
фідбеки структури зараз поговоримо про
кожну з них
і так не конкретно напиши план уроку про
вулкани конкретно напиши план уроку про
вулкани для сьомого класу учням 10-12
років бо вони різні в різних країнах
тривалий ліс уроку 45 хвилин додай додай
практичну частину там написано
поїхали Зараз ми дійдемо до всього
цікавого зворотній зв'язок оце крута
штука Вкажіть що вам сподобалося що вам
не сподобалось дивитися на відповідь
якась вона там вам трішки не подобається
проаналізуйте можливо вам якась частина
з неї подобається частина ні скажіть
йому що вам сподобалося чи ні він
навчіться з вами працювати але далі
проект
те що я казав можна перегенерувати
історію Якщо вам щось не сподобалося
подивитися на декілька варіантів і
уточніть наприклад як ця частина вортопу
стосується навчальних цілей
далі а тепер оце все це для того для
чого ви тут зібрались а натомія
мегапронту і так якщо ви хочете написати
гарний фронт пам'ятаємо Він гарно
пам'ятає Framework він знає як говорить
юрист з 20-річним стажем Ну типу
стилістика як там не знаю Говорить медик
з п'ятирічним стажем Ну приблизно він
розуміє стилістику і фреймворки тому
коли ви робите його роль кажете йому ти
той то той то і деталізуйте і починає
думати як той то той то Далі ви кажете
там завдання і кроки для його виконання
далі контекст з додатковою інформацією
або приклади Як має виглядати результат
або пояснення фреймворків які він
повинен використати або ж ну це я
взагалі вважаю що обмеження треба
вказувати завжди
є така теорія творчих обмежень вона є
для людини важлива Якщо вам сказати що
завтра у вас
мільярд доларів ви будете сидіти
отримати куди їх витратити якщо у вас
обмежити і сказати завтра тисячі доларів
ви розумієте Куди її витрачати зразу
набагато швидше в науці теорія творчих
обмежень приміняється і фізиці і так
далі Коли ви спеціально вам треба там
зробити політику десь ну наприклад
злетіти От і ви Ну до цієї задачі не
дуже зрозуміло як підібратися і ви
починаєте різні рамки накладати А якщо
це повинно бути легке тіло намагайтесь
там щось вивести потім Окей якщо воно
повинно там дешево коштувати А якщо так
якщо так А якщо так і десь на стиці
конференців може виявитися гарна ідея
критерії успіху оце також дуже важлива
штука скажіть йому що буде вважатися
успішною для вас відповіддю якщо Ну якщо
ви можете це сформулювати формат
результату ви можете його попросити в
будь-якому вигляді своєї дати вам
результат
приклад Ти вчитель інформатики твої
завдання підготувати програму
практичного занять і з програмування
мовою я вас скрип зроби наступне напиши
навчальні цілі використовуючи
текстономію облома запропонуй практичні
завдання та форма серії для кожної цілей
напиши програму заняття відповідно до 9
грн я інвенс я не знаю просто як це
швидко робив
обмеження заняття триватиме 90 хвилин з
нею 15 хвилин перерви проводилися онлайн
узумі учні ще не мають досвіду
програмування уява скрипт формат
відповіді
табличка з навчальними цілями
практичними завданнями теорію
другу яку ми Його попросили приклад
розкладу заняття у форматі час який саме
івент типа привлечь внимание І так далі
і завдання приклад завдання або теорії і
рухались далі да ваш експертиза визначає
потенціал shi пам'ятаєте все перевіряємо
сумніву
Окей і так дуже класний лайфхак якщо ви
самі не знаєте які йому Пром
сформулювати ви можете почати з
запитування до нього цього це гарний
лайфхак який допоможе там цей ефект чи
то аркушу перед тим як йому щось задати
вже вам допомогти що мені потрібно тобі
сказати щоб допомогти мені скласти
резюме на певну вакансію він вам
перелічить і ви складете гарніший фронт
креативні фронти які ви можете
використовувати на уроках А що якщо щось
не відбулося наприклад або там за кілька
хвилин там до події Як ти думаєш що було
і тому подібне розвивати творче мислення
у дітей розвивати якісь причину на
святкові зв'язки як це може бути цікаво
для вивчення історії чи ще чогось і це
зовсім не складна штука зовсім ти той то
той то той то почнімо дебати і тому
подібне ти філософ прокоментуй наступну
подію
і так оця штучка покращує фронти
заходити туди вбиваєте свій фронт то
вона допомагає
так і ці хвилює плагіат використання
штучного інтелекту і так далі два
інструменти які перевіряють чи був там
штучний інтелект тому подібне а не
забувайте що
будь-якому разі буде регуляція штучного
інтелекту в будь-якому разі буде історія
про те що діти використовують його або
на уроках або позову роками і тому
подібне тому якщо ви хочете щоб
наприклад студенти учні використовували
цю історію ви можете разом проробити
етику використання штучного інтелекту
правили якісь або ше ти вказуєш що
частина згенерована або вказуючи яка
саме і тому подібне єдине що я вас дуже
прошу хоча б активних цих історіях
використовуйте це тому що це значно
оптимізує вашу роботу і зробить учнів
набагато більш розумними чорт би реально
бо ви бачили чому
так домашнє завдання ми згенерували за
допомогою чату gpc ви можете спробувати
Просто якщо вам не хочеться чогось
іншого випробувати можете спробувати з
таких історій це ми Чад GPT сказали що
Ми прочитали лекцію для освітян
запропонуй два варіанти перших домашніх
завдань які вони можуть зробити щоб у
вас була хоч якась практика якщо чесно
це згенеровано за допомогою штучної
інтелекту і я попередив Якщо чесно я ну
дуже
нещодавно дороблював презентацію так
скажімо бо був ну сильно сильно зайнятий
Я навіть їх не читав там не дурнях хоча
б Ні ну більш-менш нормально
і так ми навіть встигли вот Нічого собі
якщо що в Фейсбуці Ну я доволі молодим
стерео Facebook тому я тут такий Ілюха
Філіпов три вот е-е можете заходити
читати я багато Пишу про освітні
методики та про наші проекти ми їх
робимо З любов'ю ой Дуже якісно дуже
великою нетерпінністю до профанації і
фігні Ми сподіваємося що в нашій освіті
цього
буде все менше і менше прикладаємо всіх
зусиль до цього дуже вам дякую і є час
на питання це взагалі неймовірно
дякую
будь ласка ваші запитання У кого є у нас
7 хвилин на запитання
ні в кого немає запитань ці вже хочуть
робити домашні завдання все Так детально
розказав А я якщо чесно в шоці що так
швидко Ну а взагалі Давайте тоді
інтерактив зворотній зв'язок будь ласка
тоді я вам поставлю запитання Може хтось
там коротко відповісти не знаю від себе
що сподобалось що не сподобалось щось
дізналися нового не дізналися спробуєте
чи ні і тому подібне
о Роксолана о і Тут іще зараз секундочку
Добре Алло Добрий день
ви казали потім вже будемо
використовувати дивитися наскільки він
підходить скільки не підходить А так
одразу Ну треба тестувати все треба
прогнати через себе потім вже
впроваджувати абсолютно точно да да
супер супер точно да
я хочу подякувати за дуже корисні поради
ми ще користувалися чатом чи по цій
раніше але ну ці поради були дуже слушні
обов'язково буде використовувати Дякую
вам Клас дякую Я радий
патруль
користувалися були дійсно проблеми але
те що йому можна запропонувати бути
вчителем або юристким або Медиком це
крита ідея я про це не думала і тепер
буду це використовувати дякую
Доброго дня Скажіть будь ласка
коли Я розказала про цей час своїм
колегам багато хто з них такі застороги
почав що діти не будуть навчатися і
будуть
Як ви вважаєте на вашу думку
дивіться у мене на це я
нещодавно до речі рефлексував цю історію
і тут є одна певна загроза давайте От і
чесно скажу яку бачать загрозу головну я
бачу таку загрозу що ми не зможемо дітям
нам буде ще складніше дітям студентам
відповідати на запитання навіщо навіщо
щось вчитель і так далі тобто Якщо
раніше було складно відповісти там на
запитання навіщо логарифми або навіщо
тригонометрії і це була искусство то
зараз коли є цей інструмент і будуть
з'являтися інші інструменти нам буде
складно відповідати наприклад навіщо
читати якщо ти можеш загнати текст і
тому подібне тому найбільший виклик це
справді для викладача педагога зрозуміти
як пояснити дитині що його нейронна
модель вона така сама як у чате GPT щоб
навчитися і розпізнавати гарний текст чи
негарний написав чат GPT от це що
експертиза його підтверджується тим
рівням на якому ти самий тобі все рівно
потрібно свої нейронній мережі
прокачувати і дати зрозуміти що з часом
вже підіг треба прокачувати правильним
чином
але якщо вони не будуть працювати з цим
викликом взагалі то точно тобто якраз
Тобто їх логіка у тому що ми не будемо
використовувати тому що діти стануть
тупі якраз призведе до того що вони її
стануть такими якщо вчитель їм не
пояснить навіщо як можна використовувати
це для розвитку твого мозку і що ти
можеш набагато швидше стати розумним
Якщо будеш використовувати правильно так
використовуй так не використовують
28 числа на терещенківський 17Б це хтось
вже знає Да ми робимо новий дожилися
зараз закреслено довчилися це івент де я
спілкуюсь там з двома експертами і сфери
зараз буде з трьома про якусь важливу
тему і у нас буде саме про Recovery про
відновлення шкіл з Єгором стадним і з
Київської школи економіки Анни у Новосад
і Ігорем хворостяним радникам міністра
освіти бот це буде цікаво Ми цю тему
розглянемо з різних сторін відновлення
освітніх втрат відновлення фізичних
просторів і тому подібне Приходьте
будемо рай а і у нас буде трилоти прапор
з підписом буданова
і спеціально для цього івенту він це
зробив бо далі І ще
ще щось від третьої штурмової бригади
будуть ще й класні лоти коротше будь
ласка приходьте Я просто вже трішки
перегрівся на прожекторці да маленьке
питання да привіт
ще раз можуть зникнути завдяки нашому
чату ну елементарно 100% є щось Що
зникне 100% є щось зникне і це
низькокваліфіковані кадри по деяким
напрямках Ну наприклад очевидним я
низкою кваліфіковані кадри там в
напрямку SMM наприклад там
написання якщо ви погано пишете тексти
там наприклад для соцмереж і ви такий
SMM joom то вам треба досягнути СМС
разом з чатом GPT і тільки потім у вас
з'явиться робота але з'явиться ну таких
прикладів багато у творчих все що
пов'язано з текстом ви пам'ятаєте гарно
аналізуєте гарно генерую Тому очевидно
те що пов'язано з текстом низку
кваліфіковані люди першими почнуть це
відчувати на собі Ну далі можна
фантазувати далі Ну але це те що перше
на розум приходить низько кваліфіковані
програмісти теж саме тому що написання
коду це теж саме написання тексту по
певній логіці а він дуже гарно шарить
фреймворки А у програмуванні приборки це
основне вот тому якби алгоритму і так
далі але що з'явиться з'являться ті хто
зможуть допомагати складати промти оці
промдизайнери це вже це вже професія
тобто не буде такого що всі повторюють
роботу Я не вірю цей кар'єрний лєнти не
всі втратили роботу з'явились ті хто
обслуговують і тому подібне ну тобто
буде звичайно буде якийсь перерозподіл
але ну я не фаталіст в цьому плані Може
я помиляюся Я ще й нефролог чи як вони
називаються і не хочу претендувати
навіть я тільки
що справді працює то я знаю а
На жаль вони ще
що ви залишилися тут аж до сьогодні дуже
класно що прийшли ви круті круті Дуже
дякую Дуже дякую Я дуже дякую Ілля казав
що не встигне презентацію а встиг ще
свій івент прорекламувати ми тобі дуже
дякуємо Мені здається репно вчився
читати
презентацію чи пас слово у мене був дуже
дякуємо за цю продуктивну презентацію
насправді дуже цікава і насправді це
Перша наша панель які ми вклалися в
таймінг колеги я така щаслива що в нас
всі три панелі прийшли успішно що в нас
не було повітряних тривог в нас є 15
хвилин перерви і рівно о 16 і 45 буде
нагородження вчителів це напевно
найважливіша частина нашої конференції
бо тому що вона є для освітян вона є про
освітян міністр буде нагороджувати
вчителів Тому вже не закликають шуруп
хоча назад події можете до нього
повернутися але в 16:45 Зустрічаємося на
головній сцені Я дуже дякую вам всім за
участь Я сподіваюсь вам сподобалось
гарного дня і слава Україні
[оплески]